welcome ladies and gentlemen to the i am
not a gm
speed chess championship brought to you
by chess.com
we have a very exciting matchup for you
today which we'll get into in just a
moment first of all
i am grand master daniel merdeski and it
is my pleasure to bring this match to
you
together with the one and only ginger gm
grandmaster
simon williams simon how are you doing
on this lovely morning slash evening
i'm doing very well yeah thank you for
that lovely introduction daniel um
it's not so lovely in england i should
say it's wet it's cold it's raining it's
dark
so it's a good time to be commentating
so it's it's great to be here
commentating with you daniel and yeah
what should be a very exciting match
awesome well i'm joining it's also a
great day in charlotte so
gray all over the world but not on the
chessboard because the players today are
going to make sure that it's not grey
we have a match between uh women's fm
alicia sanoramo and international master
roberto brida we'll get into we'll get
to the players
and their pedigree in just a moment but
first let's take a quick look at the
format
uh just a quick refresher so
the bracket will be elimination matches
so the winner of each match
transitions on to the next stage and as
should be familiar to those of you who
have seen i am not a gm mattress before
this will be usual 75 minutes of five
plus one uh 45 minutes of three plus one
followed by 25 minutes of bullet each
segment with a
one second increment that's very
important and breaks in between
uh now the players are not just playing
for honor they are playing for
very very significant prizes and
uh it doesn't matter where the players
are everybody earns a prize but
simon 900 for the winner there is a lot
at stake here and uh
the players are bringing their a game
each and every match
yeah definitely i mean uh there's been
some great matches so far
i i i love the last one you know i love
danny but i love lawrence as well and
that was so so exciting
and um i hope this one lives up to all
expectations um
we should note as well that it is a sort
of handicap match because of the the
difference in rating
but the last time this happened was
between greg and
um that that was ambotes and that came
down to a one-game finish it was
just in one game so i'm expecting yeah
another
exciting exciting event daniel it's
gonna be fascinating and they
they both look to look a bit psyched up
there don't they you can see
concentration on their faces
indeed both of them and they're looking
snazzy too
i like that that uniform and uh indeed a
15 point
uh 15 point head start for alessia but
alessia
is no pushover and blitz a lot of the
viewers probably know her as
a streamer she streams very frequently
on twitch she has a large following she
plays
a lot of blitz so not only is she an
experienced blitz player but
you know when you stream a lot you you
become more experienced playing in the
limelight
and we've seen in not only this uh i am
not a gm
championship but all sorts of speed
chess championships the ability to play
under pressure
the ability to play when you know
thousands of people are watching you
uh should not be underestimated simon i
i don't know if you agree with that but
i think that might play a role here
oh well i totally agree with that daniel
i mean i i have some very bad nightmares
of uh uh of playing ben feingold with
with far too many people watching
and uh yeah that's that's something i
try to i try i still have a bit of rehab
for but um
there's a lot of pressure when when
people are watching you play blitz um
it's it's extra pressure and you can get
very nervous
you you don't want to do silly blunders
you're aware that if you make
mistakes you wouldn't normally do
everyone's there
everyone sees your mistakes and
obviously in the internet age people are
very critical as well
so um so it is it's going to be very
interesting yeah i mean
i i don't know how the match is going to
go but also 15 points is a big league
it is yeah and and roberto can't afford
too many mistakes the problem with blitz
is there's always that
that margin of uncertainty you know
anybody can miss maiden one anybody can
blunder their queen
uh but roberto a a name that might not
be
quite as well known to some of the
viewers but he is an extremely strong
blitz player
uh i saw that he leads a active youtube
channel and i i saw that he recently
posted he crossed
2800 blitz on chess.com that is nothing
to sneeze at and
i remember him playing on various sites
for many many years so
he's got quite the blitz pedigree as
well and he's a very solid international
master he's
been an im for many years uh and
together with the ability to play in the
limelight experience
also really helps so i'm really looking
forward to this matchup
the games should begin any second now as
the players you can see
alessia you can see some nervousness
perhaps
uh in the players faces but once the
game settles on
you know you usually find them full
focus mode all that
jitter's gone yeah it's it's jumping
into action isn't it and getting in the
right frame
of uh you know mind to play uh but i
i i agree alicia does look a little bit
nervous
um at the moment but i'm sure that will
disappear as they get started
um and yeah i mean i follow a lot of her
streams actually she streams quite
regularly in the mornings in the uk
so a famous stream we've done a bit of
commentary together
before but roberto going over 2800 i
have to admit that's something i've
never done
so he's clearly a good player i know
it's something you do for breakfast
daniel
you know 2800 blindfold i'm you know
you're an awesome blitz player but thank
you it's
um it's it's gonna be very exciting just
this odds match
and the way it's set up but if you're
gonna pick one player
who would you go for i'm sorry put you
on the on the spot here daniel but it's
nice to have to do that simon
i'd have to i can put my prediction out
there as well um
it's tough i mean i i would say you know
this is not necessarily
yeah it's going to be very close i think
15 minutes
is a lot though alessia is an
experienced blitz player i feel like
she's putting a lot of practice i think
it's gonna come down to the wire
i think it's gonna come down to the
bullet i'm i'm not sure
how either of these players fares in
bullet
so i'm going to okay i'll have to go
with alessia but
i'm gonna have to put a big caveat here
that uh roberto is
clearly an extremely strong blitz player
so i think if alessia can keep
a five-point lead or more going to the
bullet she's got a very good shot if not
i think uh roberto has the better shot
i'm very bad at predictions also so
ignore everything i just say
well you kind of left it quite open
there i have to say that was that was
very like
if this if that so basically they could
right yeah
exactly that was crafty that was crafty
very enlightening perspective as usual
no no it was good so good to back both
sides i mean i i mean i
i you know over 2800 it's massive but
it is 15 points i mean i'm gonna go that
alicia is going to hold on
and and win this one uh but i think it's
going to be incredibly close and
i i think you know bearing in mind
another thing alyssia has got to think
about is game play
and in the five segment especially if
she's losing
maybe she should drag the time on a
little bit as part of the rules right i
mean
resigning pretty poorly is something she
shouldn't do and that they're off daniel
they are off and they have a queen's
gamut of the first game you're
absolutely right simon this
is a timed match and you know some
people
tend to frown on late resignations but
hey that's completely within the rules
milking the clock you do it in other
sports you do it in basketball
when you milk the shot clock and there's
no reason not to do it in chess
but let's jump into the action roberto
with the white pieces
in game one just to remind people 75
minutes of
five plus one to begin that's a pretty
leisurely time control when you think
about blitz
you think about 30-second chess being
popular nowadays
lots of time here comparatively speaking
to thing because we have a
kind of a queens gambit and this might
transition if alessia takes that pawn on
d4 to an isolated queen spawn
uh type of position which of course is
very very typical but roberto can also
be the one to take on c5
yeah it's always i always find it very
exciting and interesting to start these
matches daniel because
their openings will have a major
influence on their score
obviously and it's very hard to know
when to adjust your openings when to
change openings and
a lot of people only have one opening so
we might see in this game straight away
if alicia is going to get in trouble in
the opening and if she does will she be
able to change or is she going to be
struggling with the black pieces
throughout
this competition so i feel this is the
first couple of games a good way to see
how they're going to size each other up
um because you don't want to get in bad
positions every game this is one thing
daniel wrench
unfortunately was doing against lawrence
in the french lawrence was just crushing
him in the french defense
in in the five-minute segment i don't
know if you saw that daniel but it
it was it was pretty horrible some of
the positions that
um you know that was happening there so
yeah i saw a couple
yeah they weren't pleasant were they
they weren't pleasant they used to call
him danny
french but then the french committee
decided to take away that
that nickname okay i forgot i said
anything but here alessia is spending
she's almost two minutes in by move nine
she was thinking about whether to accept
that sacrifice on d4
instead she decided to cast a complete
uh her development and keep the tension
now the ball passed into roberto's court
will he take that pawn on c5 one common
idea to take that pawn on c5
and then to fianchetto the other bishop
this is also a very typical move d5
basically compelling black i would
imagine to take that pawn
and then we're gonna see this bishop and
sconced on d5
i would say a slight ever so slight edge
for white here
uh alessia could try bishop b6 but then
she'd have to reckon with the weak pawn
bishop g4 instead pinning the knight
let's see how roberto responds to this
one
yeah it seems like a very solid start to
the game um
i mean i think uh i mean it's
interesting to know what kind of
strategies both these players
should be you know trying to go for i
guess alicia
having the 15 point lead i would
recommend that she she just tries to
play quite solid chest doesn't you know
you have to avoid blundering at this
time limit obviously or try to
but don't don't play anything too too
over the top just get long games in
until you have to take your
opportunities where you can and what
would you suggest
let's say you're a robertio's second
here
what would you suggest that his strategy
should be for the the five minute
segment
i mean definitely i think aggressive he
needs to try to win every game in the
five minute
because in the five minute portion you
have that time to think you have a
little bit less uncertainty
in the three minute portion and
especially in the bullet you have to
allow for
for some freak mistakes you know you
have to allow for some blunders in the
five minute you can
you can take your time you can really
focus on trying to outplay your opponent
and
given the head start roberto has to try
his best to do that to sharpen the
position when possible
to take some calculated risks but as you
said not to go
over the top for him either so we see a
trade of dark squared bishops has been
offered
if alessia takes that bishop then
white's queenside pawn structure is
is slightly ruined uh nothing major
though and white does get that b
file for one of his rooks so we see
quite a few trades here the position
quite tame
but uh i'm beginning to get a little bit
worried here about alessia's clock now
two minutes almost two minutes and
counting
yeah it's a bit of a worry i mean like
you have to get yourself into the match
and get getting the right rhythm
i think is very important not moving too
quickly but not moving too slowly
and finding that rhythm and adjusting
when the time
segment changes is going to be another
big factor i think it's okay at the
moment but
if it gets down to the one minute
section then then you start panicking
right then you have to
up the tempo and to be fair it's not
such a complex position this one it's
one position where
you probably should be moving a little
bit quicker because there's no outright
tactics there
maybe this is a sign of some slight
nerves on alicia's side
um but hopefully she gets over them
quickly yeah and she needs to decide
whether to take this fish i mean she can
what you can do is take and
perhaps simplify the position further
with 95. uh something like that comes to
mind but
you can also defend the bishop with with
the move like queen e7 either way she's
got to make a decision because
yeah the time disparity is huge she does
take that bishop
let's see what she does here maybe bring
the rook into the game just rook a to d8
comes to mind as well
um again like you said simon yep and
that's exactly what she does the
position is simple enough
not that much is going on tactically
speaking uh
but white definitely has that slight
edge now what roberto needs to decide i
think is
is he going to play this move g4 get rid
of the pin but accept
some sort of weakness of his king side
maybe maybe g4 queen c4 something like
this
uh pretty committal decision though so
uh he's got
something to chew on as well and we see
that he is chewing on that
yeah i mean he's got he's got a lot of
time on the clock he's got nearly well
two-minute advantage really what they're
about so
he might as well i mean the thing that i
think everyone watching this must bear
in mind when they're playing chess as
well
it's time management is so important in
in blitz or in long play
and if you've got obvious moves in the
opening you should generally be moving
quickly there's no reason to think but
every chess game will have i'd say like
one to three critical moments
and it's those situations where you need
to tank a bit of time
and work out what to do because they're
the ones that are going to change
the effect of the game so you've got to
manage your time well
play the obvious moves quickly and i
like what alicia is doing here daniel
putting the rugs on that open file
playing logical moves
getting ready to double up seems like uh
it seems like a nice plan that she's
she's now found here
yeah i like that quite a bit and uh if
roberto tries to secure his bishop with
c4 then
he gives up the b4 square always
important when you make these pawn moves
what squares are weakened as a result
and if white stick
or flex sticks the knight on b4 black's
going to be very very solid here with no
pressure down the b-file so roberto has
to find alternate arrangements
uh for that bishop on d5 maybe an airbnb
somewhere
but it's not exactly clear where uh okay
that was
not funny at all if you move the bishop
away then right now
daniel sorry you keep putting yourself
down with your jokes your jokes are good
i'm liking it okay you've thrown some
good jokes in already
you know you see i'm used to commentate
with robert hess and and he's very mean
to me so i'm not used to
being nice to you thank you we want more
jokes
we want more definitely i appreciate
that i'll do my best so
but roberto here uh the computer's
showing a small
edge for white i'm actually not sure
if uh in human terms white is actually
any better i mean i'm not seeing a very
satisfactory response to work f28 we see
that reflected in the clock roberts are
taking
a big big chunk of that time advantage
to think this situation through what is
he going to do here
yes i'm i mean it's it's not obvious
here
at the moment i mean it's a very simple
plan for black and
the other thing you want i think when
you're playing blitz chess i don't know
if you find this daniel i mean you're
one of best blitz players around but for
me certainly i think for most
most mortals is simple plans or you want
to have positions which you understand
well
in the middle game so you can play your
moves really quickly you know you don't
have to
you don't have to think too much and
queen c4 now played and
this does look very logical to at least
get the queen
out of that pin and to pressurize the
pawn on c5
but that bishop takes f3 is a very good
move i think alessia is going to follow
it with 95
trying to simplify the position further
that was a very important resource
because the c5 pawn is saying so roberto
might actually consider taking with a
pawn
i know that sounds weird but at least
that way you preserve your bishop if you
take with a bishop
after 95 that leads to a further trade
and you know as we discuss the more the
position simplifies the easier it is to
play for black
and roberto does take with the with the
bishop so let's see what
what will happen i'm thinking even rook
takes d1 and 95 is fine
or 95 immediately although that might
lose a pawn to rook takes d7
so rook t7 is probably going to happen
counter attacking black screen we think
this is going to happen then alicia
might take with the queen
and white might be up upon here it's not
the best fun
but maybe some chances remaining for
roberto who's chewing on this situation
yeah and now look at the time i think
the time is going to now going to be a
major
factor in this game to be honest i mean
they're they're both got 30 seconds i
know
they're getting a bit of increment every
move uh one there's only one second
though
and they're gonna have to now change
their tempo they've played quite slowly
to this point
sometimes you have to sacrifice the
quality of your play
just to play some quick moves right uh
and alicia thinking here
i think that move knight takes f3 should
have been played a bit quicker
yep white now taking over the file but
so far alicia's holding hasn't played
any mistakes doing very
absolutely and this should be with
correct player draw but i doubt it will
be somehow
because it's just uh anything could
happen bullet chess hyper bullet being
played here 20 seconds for both sides
and we can just see five on five well
not on the same flank but equal material
rook and queen
nothing major happening i would just
take this and go rook to b8
rook to b8 push that pawn through that's
exactly what alessia does operating with
confidence blink pass roberto now with
less time
spending a little bit too much time in
those critical moments it's b4
is black better here even possibly the
king definitely bring that king and king
to c5
black king makes it in time and
roberto's got to think about making a
draw here
definitely i mean c7 though rook c7 lots
of counter play on the board yeah okay i
think
i shouldn't have allowed that move yeah
i'm sure yeah i mean
behind a passport normally a very
important thing to do but the white
rooks become active and with little time
on the clock here 10 seconds left
she's got to make an important decision
do you give that away she's given the
pawn
roberto not taking it yeah bringing the
king behind now rook to d8 maybe take
active counter play two seconds she's
got gotta make a move yeah she's gonna
she's gotta make a move
oh and now roberto can win that b3 pawn
although it still remains within the
bounds of a draw
oh she gotta move oh on a flag
oh we can see the reactions there
already
she's laughing that one off but i mean
that was that ending because even
roberto
roberto was kind of shocked there i
think alicia played fantastically
until allowing that rook into the
seventh rank and she just didn't up the
tempo
quite enough but positive play from her
up to that point in the game
absolutely incredible middle game play
great decision making
and it really came down to the wire you
called it simon you know when you've got
five seconds for player something's
bound to happen even in
the most dry dry of positions but
you know alessia remaining positive
she's telling this as a victory she's
doing what she needs to do
you know taking the games down to the
wire and she's going to pull some of
them out
here we see a one e6 followed by a b6 so
they've transposed into this
semi-french semi-owens game kind of
opening
and uh leslie adopting a very sensible
set up having played f3
but uh black now wants to play c5 in
these positions and break apart white's
pawn chain so
a very common response here is to play
f4 in order to meet c5 with knight f3
and keep that e5 pawn
well protected instead a3
the bishop just comes back no i mean you
would often expect that bishop to
exchange itself on c3
like in the french defense doubling uh
white's pawns there but
uh black's decided to keep that bishop i
mean again
you have to sort of decide what
structures you favor when you pick an
opening
and um i really like this move knight to
e2 and c3
i think this is a very clever maneuver
you can see white's pawn structure b2
all the way to e5 those pawns are so
strong
and if white can you know maintain those
pawns in the center of the board
i i do certainly prefer white's position
here
absolutely and we see that this has
indeed taken on the contours of a french
bishop a6
trading off that french bishop the
infamous french bishop
and and that is a very very typical idea
in the french
um and roberto doing a good job sort of
forcing alessia to make decisions
uh constantly you know should i trade
the bishop should i ignore
i don't think that's particularly
essential and i like the speed with
which alessia decided to take it
play f4 she's playing very sensible
straightforward but
uh healthy moves and white's definitely
got the edge here
yeah certainly it's nice having a space
advantage in such a position
i was thinking maybe alicia could have
played before at some stage because
i suppose there's a long term plan here
of black of pawn storming
on the queen side with a5 and b4 and
white could have taken control of both
sides of the ball possibly white's got
control
i'd say on the king side with pawn on f4
but having a pawn on b4
you've got space advantage everywhere so
um this is a very blocked position
now the pawn structure when they become
locked like this
it's a lot of maneuvering that's going
to go on not some quick tactics but
getting your pieces to the best squares
and
now alicia's gone for this b3 and this
is a this is a very
i'd say in some ways double-edged
positional choice because you can see a
c3 pawn
is is quite weak in a lot of positions
uh i'm not sure if that was the way to
play or not
would you have played b3 there daniel
yeah it's interesting because it
i agree with the assignment i think i'm
not sure who the opening of the
queen side favors but it seems to be
black another idea that i indicated with
an arrow
a queen trade would favor black here
because white seems to be the one trying
for this king side attack with f5 so
queen c4
a timely and there we have it uh right
on cue queen c4
alessia correctly declining the queen
trade but now look at black's queen
entrenched on that square that is a huge
asset
and now roberto trying to get his knight
to b5 attacking that c3 pawn which uh of
course now can be attacked
with the c file being opened maybe a4
alessia should consider to stop the
knight from getting to b5 another very
important thing in blitz
prophylaxis stopping your opponent's
plans that can be
so hard to deal with in a blitz game
instead alessia going for king g2 trying
to go rook h1
but simon not sure that that's a very
effective plan
if she does play rocketrone because
black can always cover a check on aj
with bishop f8
i totally agree i like your a4 move i
mean chess is about two things pushing
your own ideas but you need to stop
your opponent's ideas and uh i think
this knight maneuver
that uh roberto played there was very
clever and if white could have stopped
it white should have stopped it but
i do have to go back to this b3 move i
mean there is a rule
which is well worth bearing in mind i
mean i think b4 you could say breaks the
rule but in general
you should play moves pawn moves on the
area of the ball where your weakest
this is just like a general rule and
because black's got the space on the
queen side
and white is going for this f5 break you
should avoid playing pawn moves
opening up the area of the board where
your weakest and i think alicia
opened up that area of the board and
it's only helped black
and i think here she could just be in a
bit of trouble
she definitely is and as we indicated
this check on h8 it looks scary
but black simply goes bishop f8 and and
there's just no follow-up
and and to compound that problem black
is taken upon
but every subsequent trade
is in knight f8 is also possible every
subsequent trade is in black's favor
alessia also stands to lose this a3 pawn
and if she does black's gonna have two
connected passers on the queen side this
is looking
very very grim and again a big time
advantage here for
roberto who's kept his clock over four
minutes
that's right and um okay so trying some
check
i mean you can't even grab that pawn if
white tries to grab that's an evil
idea very nasty and this is the kind of
[__]
oh did she play it she played it and
this is one of those situation talk
about should she even play on for a
minute here
because every minute she gains on the
clock you know
she's got this lead because it's a
handicap match it's part you know you're
allowed to play on i i feel like maybe
she should
at least play on here i know it's people
can say it's morally wrong but
it's in the rules so why not you never
know
yeah part of the game i think i think
it's part of the match it's legitimate
i think she should try to take on on aa
take that rook maybe go f5
stir some things up you can also wear
your opponent down
by by being resilient in these positions
even if you know you're gonna lose
uh just forcing your opponent to think a
little bit and here we see alessia
taking her time
again she's nothing wrong with that
every second is gordon she's having a
nice sip of tea there or something just
she's saying right i'm probably losing
here i'm just gonna maybe also it's good
time
to have a think about what what your
strategy in the opening should be
because
of course we now know she knows what
happened in game one so she could be
thinking okay now i'm gonna have black
in the next game
if the opening goes the same way what
what do i need to do differently
if i lost that first game so it's a good
time to sort of reflect
on positions you've had even on because
you don't get much time to do that when
the match is
in your face um but she is playing on
here
there's a capture on f5 it looks like
it's going to go two games up
um but still a long way to go i mean
this segment you can see the
the the clock ticking down there's still
56 minutes left daniel
uh it's a lot of games they can get in
at that time
definitely but looking at the score it's
only gonna be two to fifteen
that is indeed a long road to climb and
unless they're trying her best to
just throw things up but she's just down
too much the queen queen is the queen of
the queen
and uh yeah you know i took her q took a
sip of tea
and um just gotta gear yourself up for
the next game i like your point about
thinking through the openings
if you are taking this time it is a good
idea to think through okay what
might i be doing not as well what could
i be doing better
what do i need to tweak uh you know any
kind of
small things that you could be telling
yourself could have a compound impact
later in the match so yeah and this
one's gonna
be in the books now 2 to 15 is our score
and yeah 55 minutes left in the five
minute portion plenty of time
and they're off for the third game so
okay well we have a change of opening
here in the first game uh roberto played
the queen's pawn up and now going into
what's called the
english opening um and an opening i've
played
a lot and i i think if you played the
english daniel a bit as well you're
you've played everything haven't you
don't i've played everything a few times
but my question is have you played the
english
because it's called english or is
because you like the positions
is it like an obligatory thing for
english grandmasters to play it
i i think it has to be i think i think
you should always play an opening
from the area of the country or from
well now that i'm just thinking what
what could be a really bad choice there
i mean i guess french people play that
you know there must be a bad choice but
french people's play the french
dutch people should play the dutch
what's the what's the worst choice i'm
just trying to think the worst
name the worst is named after a country
yeah
is that iran the russians pretty solid
that's the petrov
russian is not a bad choice um yeah
because there is a great choice
spanish is a great choice yeah if you
live in spain you're doing well
because there is that um there is that
saying that any opening
named after an animal is just terrible
so you got the elephant yeah
you got the orangutan yeah so
but i think after a country generally
openings with a country name are better
right
they're they're they're more sort of
that i can't think of any bad ones off
the top of my head
yeah i can't either i think the people
of that country would rise up
you know if it was uh not a sufficiently
sound opening
yeah right now people people are saying
the hedgehog
is a good opening well you know it's
okay but it's not it's not fantastic
either
um but back to the game now lots of
things happening
here already i i love that licia puss in
that h-pawn
because i love it when harry the h pawns
going up the board but
but also you also have to be careful
your center right daniel and
i'm a bit you know you should only be
able to do wing attacks
when you're controlling the center of
the board and i'm not sure
that alicia had that center under
control enough to
get a way of doing a wing attack really
yeah i mean oddly enough she played h6
and then after b4 oh wow the pawn is
untouchable dude
now she played h5 so i'm not sure if
that was a mouse slip or or if she
decided to respond to that move b4 with
h5 but this end game is is actually
really really bad for black for several
reasons first of all
you hinted at this alessia's king and
one of the biggest misconceptions is
that
attacks are off the table in an end game
that's not quite true i mean this is
more like a queen less middle game
black's king is uncastled and
not out of the woods another thing
that's tough and that's why i really
like the move rook v8
that frees up that c8 bishop which
didn't used to be able to develop
because b7 would have been hanging
if i were roberto now i would try to
strike in the center as quickly as
possible attack those puns and that is
what he does with that a4
attacking that e5 pawn certainly
we've got to remember here this is the
kind of position where you could try to
castle as black
um but you can't because you moved your
king i'm pretty sure i've done that
before i get into a position i forget
i've moved my king
i go to i go to carlson like what's
wrong what's wrong with chess.com it's
not allowing me to cast
a second glitch we discovered
i've done that even over the board where
i i wasn't sure if i could castle
so i started furiously hunting my
scoresheet okay
is there like a zero zero there no and
yeah it's a terrible feeling when you
realize you've like taken a queen on
move two and then move the king back to
e1
no castle there was a there was a famous
case of this in uh
you know some of the strongest players
in the world i mean i i think this is
roughly how the story went it went with
uh courchenoy courtroom was one of the
strongest players
never to become world champion i'm sure
a lot of people out there have heard of
him
there's a film recently over him
fighting uh in 1978 for the world
championships against karpov and
in one of the world championship cycles
um when you
when you try to get to play the world
champion simon sorry wait wait a minute
yeah i think i'll say just what happened
i think she just now slips bishop b3
oh dear oh dear oh and she grabs her
head yeah
that and roberto kind of raising his
eyebrows there
all right i'll take it yeah okay i mean
this is looking like
it's gonna go 15 free so far yeah
but sorry not to interrupt you no no
again
i think this one caught snow basically
he was one of the best players in world
time and he had to get the arbiter
and he had to ask the arbiter am i
allowed to castle queenside
is my rook allowed to castle through the
bishops diagonal
so he wasn't even sure about the
castling rules
even though he was one of the best
players in the world and the arbiter had
to
tell him the rules there uh okay but
freeno up in the match
and it'd be good to see alicia get back
into this one
and we see a french defense she got a
very good position as white
in the last game can she do it again i
think she should play exactly the same
opening absolutely well
but not this b3 move yeah if it ain't
broke don't fix it
she had a great she had a great opening
and uh like you said i think
if she focuses on the king's side in
this game
she would have every chance to to get an
even better position
so here we go f3 i like that choice and
maybe roberto will modify his opening
strategy a little bit because i didn't
like his position there
but bishop g5 i don't remember in the
first game i think alessia developed her
bishop to e3
yeah she's going for a slightly more
aggressive setup here which
does make a lot of sense that knight is
now in a pin
meaning it can't move and also white has
possibilities of using
her center here and alicia might be able
to go e5
putting pressure on the pin but she's
now just maneuvering the bishop around
does black want to play g5
looks a little bit a little bit over the
top the move g5 but
he's played it he's gone for it and he
and i think as you said daniel
it really is roberto who probably needs
to take more risks
because he needs to win more games so
he's he's got a he's got to stir things
up and he
he's done that with g5 but obviously
daniel very double-edged move because
the black king
it doesn't want to castle king side now
because you pushed your pawns away
and it would be lacking any protection
right but this movement
g3 that may not seem significant but it
does help
roberto get this knight to h5 now knight
takes g3 is a
you know it's a significant positional
threat you don't want to give away this
bishop
uh because that creates a weakness in
these dark squares but the problem is if
you go bishop f2
then black plants the knight on f4 that
doesn't seem like a big deal but it
could be annoying it could force the
other bishop to f1
and um alessia with this decision she
goes knight g2 but now roberto is almost
definitely going to snap
up that bishop uh maybe lsa is planning
to take with the h fun
and open up that rook on h1 that would
be an interesting approach and then
castle
uh queen side you don't see that every
day so
roberto's got to decide is it worth it
uh to give white that h
file i think it is i think you should
take that bishop
probably worth grabbing the bishop i
think i mean again
unbalance it this is the other sort of
natural move isn't it daniel you can
play because
black was the problem with black's
position white's got these two
very strong pawns in the center of the
board and black doesn't really have
any control over the center so a move
that roberto just played
tries to get some influence in the
center and and complicates the position
somewhat
so a free i think looks like a very good
response so forcing that bishop
now to to give itself up i'd imagine on
c3
um and we're going to have i mean was
there a bishop d6 there i was wondering
as well was interesting but
oh this sort of uh gave this as a
possibility didn't it
that that yeah that actually was a
pretty serious possibility just planting
that bishop they're stopping black from
castling
that bishop is very hard to kick away i
mean it's right in the middle of things
but
black is no good way to to chase that
bishop away
and and it could combine perhaps with a
with a knight on c7
that would have been very unpleasant so
yeah and now bishop d6 even here
might be pretty good i like him i like
it i like it
see i think this bishop f2 this is a a
classical sort of
i i hate to say but mistake but you
should always look for the most
active move always and retreating the
bishop there
when there's a more active possibility
you know it's not the right way to go so
always look at going forwards as long as
it's sound of course and
this one i think it's still okay for
white daniel i still prefer white's
position
looking funny but i like the idea of
going straight into black's position as
well
no absolutely bishop d6 was was very
strong but
white's position remains very solid and
um
the problem with roberto's position is
he's over extended himself slightly he's
weak on both sides of the board
i would just castle if i were alessia
talk the king away
and go after you know one of black's
many vulnerabilities you could try to
get a knight to b5
that's exactly what she does she's
playing this very very well d takes c5
also an option just opening up the
position
if i were roberto here i'd scramble to
finish my development maybe go knight c6
try to get some clarity in the position
also which should be mentioned knight b5
here oh that looks juicy
and that bishop on a5 not to be
underestimated either that could be
trapped
this is a perfect situation to throw the
knight into the position
get it into d6 that square where the
bishop is and also
you have ideas of going c3 and b4
trapping
the bishop will she play it and this is
this is the perfect time to play it
because you've
controlled the center developed your
pieces got your king castle you've done
all the basic
opening things you're into the middle
game when you're in the middle game you
need to start playing proactively
creating frets
and there we have it
and now she's got to find an act to
follow maybe take on c5
you mentioned the idea of c3 the problem
with something like that might be a6
so white has limited time to follow up
on this i would probably
take on c5 trying to get that line of
fire going
between white's queen and the d6 pawn so
for example dc bc
and then something like bishop c4 trying
to hit where it hurts trying to attack
that d6 bond further
and alessia takes on c5 so what is your
running run
opening up the position and now it's can
she okay so bishop c4
and the only downside of playing this is
of course the bishop can now
come back to c7 that's true where black
has
this defensive strategy in the center
she's gone for your plan though
i think she's playing this game very
well i think her nerves are gone
you know no matter what the result she's
doing all the right things okay the king
comes up
that's a nice move though
i was going to say where does the black
king go in this game there's nowhere
safe
for the black king so this is a safe
it's going to get you don't always need
to castle sometimes it's safe for
leaving it in the center behind the
pawns
and uh now white's got to decide what to
do i mean can you play g4 bishop g3
this kind of craziness is this the way
to go because you want to be
aggressive here don't you daniel if you
can now that you've moved that king
uh keep the tempo up against black's
position
and f4 i really like the spirit of that
move alessia trying to open up this
diagonal for the bishop so for example
knight takes f4 knight f4 gf and she's
going to give a check on h4
further weakening that king f6 maybe you
can strike with e5
we're gonna see some fireworks in this
game but roberto a6 very level-headed
finally gets rid of that knight and now
he's
he's a little bit more free to deal with
the opening of the king side i would
take that pawn on f4
because that also establishes a square
on e5
for this d7 right that could be a pretty
meaningful outpost
that makes sense okay the knight goes
back i mean again retreating
if you can avoid it you should probably
avoid it and now
it's very published with the opening of
the f-file you've got
i mean this is this is whose king is
safer here yeah i like it i like g5
certainly certainly luckily there's
bishop g3 i guess all right
a bit of a save but it's one of those
kind of hidden moves though isn't it d5
the queen on b8
suddenly strikes all the way across the
board and if you're not if you're not on
the ball you could easily miss
that queen takes h2 uh idea there um
okay so she's moved their knight now to
g3
you know i i would be thinking night
knight e5 is a lovely square for that
night isn't it yeah
and queen g a queen h7 could also be
made with a problem 36 seconds that's
what really concerns me it's such a
complicated middle game
yeah and burning more clock on every
move here
it seems to me that roberto has
overtaken the initiative that king on e7
now looks perfectly safe
and as robert s always points out snyder
on g3
very bad situation the knight is
completely circumscribed by a pawn that
pawn on e6 guarding f5
and queen g8 here that now would be a
great time for that and he does it
yup yeah it does look like the black
king is now well defended and if
anything it's the white king but the
time situation is the major issue here
even though alicia has played very well
roberto has defended brilliantly i have
to say there's loads of times he could
have gone wrong
and uh in this situation alicia has got
to up the tempo
still very unbalanced if i was white i'd
be trying to
maybe get my queen to the center get a
you know or try to attack on the f file
but
there's no obvious way uh this is going
to achieve so much here
so it's the time just keep an eye on the
clock i think most important one
um love it'd be great to see alyssia get
it get a win on the board you know
as well at the moment she is free down
uh how much time do we have left in this
segment got 41 minutes but she's played
a very good game here
absolutely and she was very close knight
b5 one got the sense that
she was very close to delivering a fatal
blow but roberto finding some very
creative approach to the position here
we see
the position remains very complicated i
don't think white is worse
i love the move b5 alessia continuing to
attack in g4 the
position just explodes anything can
happen but 10 seconds on the clock
this is going to be so hard to to
survive in
and this is this is a really strong move
in your opponent's tiny trouble
that doesn't seem great because now the
rook is extremely king
yeah ghgh knight g4 is going to be a
killer
yeah the white king now has proven to be
the weak king and uh
this g4 is such a good mood to play when
your opponent's got no time on the clock
because defending
against such an attack you have to be so
accurate if you don't find the right
move
you're just going to get checkmated
which i think is going to occur here one
second down
this is looking pretty grim now yep and
roberto is going to pick up
a bunch of pieces here rook takes h3 is
going to come in as well
and this one is just over upper rook and
yeah d5 is also perfectly good
bishop's coming to life now right yeah
but you know what i hope alicia
takes something away from that game
because she played really well i mean
okay she lost
roberto playing well of course but uh
alicia
was on the offensive there was pushing
that opening
that she's playing is giving her lots of
good positions and she needs to keep
playing that one so
just she will get a win if she keeps
doing that i'm sure absolutely
but uh before anything else happens we
are going to go on
a very short half time we're going to
let the players catch their breaths
and we're going to catch our breasts
it's been very very exciting so far and
the best is still to come short break
and then we will return for the second
part
of the five minute segment of this i am
not a gm speed chest championship
matchup
welcome back to thechess.com i am
not a gm speed chess championship
we're in the midst of a very exciting
match between international master
roberto molina and
women's feed a master alessia santoramo
we have the second half of the
five-minute segment coming your way
in just one moment simon
your thoughts about the match so far
your thoughts on the players respective
chances as they settle into this match
i think there's pos positive things from
both sides to be honest i mean
roberto is looking very good he's
looking like he's handling his time
better than alicia and he's keeping the
pressure up he defended well
in the last game uh but alicia is
getting
good positions especially with the white
pieces the she's just gotta
i guess i don't know just use you focus
a little bit more and use her time a
little bit better
i mean the way it's going um i'm trying
to work out in my head the odds
of roberto catching up alicia so there's
a 11 point
lead we're only in the five minute
section and
if it does continue this way then i
think he will probably be favorite
but let's hope alicia gets a win on the
board soon
absolutely and if she continues to play
aggressively especially the white pieces
you know roberto might save a couple of
those positions but
one time out of four or five i think
alessia will
find the moves necessary to uh to finish
the job
and we see another english here uh the
first time roberto played the english
things didn't go that well for alessia
she had played e5
now we see that she plays the more
queen's gambit set
up and and here we see a nimzo indian
name so anyone for the first time in the
match which line we're about to play e3
very reputable one of the most popular
uh responses to the
nimzo indian and knight g2
yeah so this is a pretty solid start
from from both sides here
and i think it's clever choice of
roberto playing the english
we're talking about a lot of this is
sizing up each other's openings trying
to work out
where you're getting the advantages and
um roberto did
get a crushing position from the english
in the first game this is
more positive from alicia but slightly
cramped here
uh hence why she's crashing out with a5
i mean it's the kind of position where
you know your pieces can lack oxygen to
breathe right when you're playing with
black
look at alicia's pieces on the queen
side she's got to try and do something
with those with those pieces there
right and oftentimes what you'll see in
these positions is the bishop comes out
to a6
and uh you get this kind of cat and
mouse game who flinches first waiting
game
black's other idea more active idea is
to eventually get e5 in as you said
simon
get a little bit more breathing room a
little bit more oxygen for your pieces
uh what are white's ideas white's ideas
are are generally to kind of just push
black off the board sometimes you'll see
an attack on the c6 spawn
i know that pawn doesn't look meaningful
right now but you know mark my words
uh there are certain positions where
this fight it is a backward one and it
can be attacked
in some you know future reality in 2028
by a queen that perhaps lands on a4 so
we'll see how this plays out i love what
elise is doing here
that bishop on c4 beautiful and it can
be supported by
b5 when black can just chill
i i don't really an e5 instead that also
seems pretty sensible
i think alyssia are playing very well in
this game i think she's doing things
perfectly in actual fact i mean
i was talking about her queen side
pieces she's put that light square
bishop on this perfect square
and now this proactive move i like this
e5 because it's
it's very tempting just to sit there and
not be proactive but if you've got a
chance to grab the initiative
then take it and she's played this move
and also her time handling
much better than this exactly i was
gonna say yeah it's good
it's very positive sign so far yeah over
four minutes and i think during the
break
you know one of the biggest challenges
in these matches is pulling out the
positive
you know taking the games you lose and
saying well this is what i did well this
is what i want to repeat
uh it's not all about starting from a
clean slate every single game
and i think alessia told herself you
know i'm
i'm making the right moves i'm playing
with the right kind of style i just want
to play a little bit faster trust myself
a little bit more and that's exactly
what she's doing in this opening
as we see roberto taking on v6 he's the
one who flinches first
that really liberates a lot of black's
pieces i would take back
probably with the queen so that uh that
knight could come out to e5 and threaten
bishop d3 with a pin
but i mean obviously you could also
stick with the knight that also seems
pretty yeah she takes for the knight
i like that a little bit less because
now roberto is going to stick a knight
on d4 and that c6 spawn
what did i tell you now that pawn's
going to cause black a little bit of
problems here but rook c8
uh black is still completely fine yeah
it's a
kind of yeah brook c8 maybe at some
point black can play c5 but then you
then you have a problem with your other
right in the middle of the board so
this is this is the situation both of
these black pawns they may look quite
safe
and when you're trying to attack a pawn
structure as white's doing it's always a
good idea to look at the base of the
pawn structure
which pawn is holding up those pawns
it's the c6 pawn at the moment
white attacks that if that pawn moves
the other pawn becomes weak
and um you know this is this has gone a
little bit better now
for roberto here but still nothing too
serious
for alicia very solid position nothing
immediate should happen at the moment
no immediate danger to either side yeah
i'm a little bit worried about e4 and
that's exactly what he plays
for yeah and yeah now his pieces get out
bishop to f4 knight to f5 the problem is
um if if alessia and i can maybe show
this on the analysis board if alessia
just takes it's an instructive moment
just take everything on e4
what you see is that once that outer
shell
disappears the position collapses really
really quickly that knight
coming to c6 bishop coming to h7
just as an example you know you could
just see the whole position collapsing
so
a move like e4 needs to be treated very
very precisely let's say you're playing
rook after d8
but now the bishop could come out to f4
or you could consider pawn to e5
pushing away that knight because that
pawn's untouchable bishop f4 bishop d
but now e5 is crushing
now e5 is crushing and it is the c6 pawn
that ultimately is going to do alessia
in if remember to play z5
it's it's amazing how much this position
has changed over the course of a couple
of moves because
we're just saying how how good alicia's
position was and i was praising
her e5 move but in actual fact that e5
move
it needed to be uh followed up very
precisely because you are changing the
nature of the position
by pushing a pawn in the center and that
one mistake
of allowing white's knight into the
position it's collapsed now
unfortunately just
really now gone totally downhill uh
for for alicia and this is going to be
another win
on the board for roberto it is
and just to come back to that pivotal
moment when
uh it's and this is very instructive
because the queen
is often not very good when it's sort of
dangling around in the center
queen takes b6 this may look less
appealing than taking with the knight
and then centralizing the queen but that
knight in the center
in point of fact is actually much much
more effective
once alicia centralized her queen that
queen had to go back
some tempos were lost and roberto was
able to strike with
e4 and then e5 here he's up in exchange
the game is not quite over
simon some precision still required but
uh it looks like he's
confidently kind of carrying this one
home
i mean uh obviously white has the the
material advantage here white doesn't
really have
any weaknesses you know when you're
playing you've got to try target
weaknesses see where the weaknesses are
can't really see many in white's
position so
it should be a win for white but again
talking about tactics for the match
alicia had this big 15 point lead at the
start
and you want the time to drag on as much
as you can is part of this
part of the process and uh i and she's
still got chances this is yeah as you
say there's always chances with pieces
on the board
the queen's on the board a mouse slip
you never know
we've had one mouse slipped from alicia
maybe roberto should
respond by giving a mouse slip away here
i don't think he will but
it's always possible in it always is
in bliss chess yeah and you know some
people say
uh you know you should allow a take back
quota for
now slips in my opinion that's part of
what makes it interesting
the technology uh is is a legitimate
part of
of being good at online chess and i
think that just adds a wrinkle i get i
get that it can be
weird but uh i think again i think it's
interesting the problem here with
alessia's position
isn't only the fact that she's down in
exchange look at that knight on d3
that knight has no escape squares so
roberto is simply threatening bishop
back to f1 trapping that knight winning
it
unless oh and the move f6 trying to
create a little helipad for that night
well now the other night drops so that's
the problem with having
these minor pieces that are kind of
dangling all over the position bishop f1
here
would end the game immediately would win
the night
yes it's looking bad and you know
throwing a knight into your opponent's
position like alicia has done with that
night is a very brave and often good
thing to do but it
has its drawbacks you can get caught in
your enemies territory
and uh and you won't be to save your
troops and that's gonna happen
to that night now now i think the next
game i i feel
is really important actually because
it's starting to roberto starting to
sort of dominate
where he in in this game and the other
games played very well here
but alicia in a in the only two other
white games she had
has got very good positions and she's
played very well
she's got white again if i was roberto
by the way i wouldn't play the same
opening i agree
100 really not working the only defense
if he does though i i think alicia has
to has to try to get something on the
board and the next one
to stop this match sort of really you
know going the wrong way
it'd be my opinion how stop the rot you
need to you need to do that
i agree i think there's something to be
said for sort of tilting the opponent
playing the same opening even though
you're not getting great positions
uh but it can be very frustrating when
you're just unable to refute
uh what you know is an unsound line uh
with that being said i think
that's not the emphasis for roberto he's
trying to get combative positions
and as far as i know he he's got a
pretty wide opening repertoire
so something like a sicilian or even a
french you know a mainline french
would would offer up a relatively
unbalanced position and would be
somewhat more sound alessia has shown
that she is very much capable of
handling herself in these tactical
positions
so roberto's got to get something a
little bit more sound but here we see
a couple more moves have to be made here
i really like what alexia is doing here
queen h6 queen takes hp trying to get to
white's king wearing him down a little
bit one way to play this would be
actually nothing occurs to me off the
top of my it's not that easy to find a
move here
that's totally watertight maybe queen to
f4 attacking that rook
and if rook h6 and queen to be it is
going to be a background checkmate that
seems
like one method but roberto and that's
what he does
uh again this is very impressive finding
this move because white has a lot of
options there that the time was ticking
down
and like so i like what alicia tried to
do there
and this is a very good technique if
your position is clearly bad or it's
going wrong
there's no point trying to keep fighting
it out in a positional game you might as
well just throw all your pieces
at your opponent's king even if you know
it's going to fail it's like a last sort
of
kamikaze attack and these attacks can
sometimes
throw your opponent off guard and get
you unexpected results so
totally the right idea but um roberto's
handling it very well he seems very calm
doesn't he i'm impressed with
how he's not phased at all at this
moment or any moment drawing this match
really
no he's he's coming into this with
experience and
he's playing very level had a chest he's
had so many of these
especially with black quite a few of
these dubious positions
and he's found creative combative ways
to defend them
and he's gotten out of bad situations
he's capitalized on good situations
so he's doing he's doing everything
right here we see a very clinical
bringing the queen back not quite for
too many pawns that b
pawn is what's going to decide the game
you can even push it to b5 right now you
don't really need to defend that g
pawn but if you wanted to you could drop
your yeah he does
alessia trying every last chance but a
rook
is a rook and that rook is right behind
that passport there it comes
b6 b7 b8 close your eyes promote the
pawn win the game
it's nice when you've got such a simple
plan as well isn't it just just
push push the b pawn get a queen and uh
there's now just be a little bit careful
obviously there is one
one second left look at the time the
times a little bit time he's gonna move
yeah and hither another the queen goes
but now finally
yeah yeah good moves
but yeah he's gonna start that this is
so calm i have to say
and uh queen 67 yeah yeah
very calm player from roberto i'm very
impressed with that and
so this game i think really is alicia's
chance okay she's
yes she's lost five on the drop now and
she's got the white pieces
i don't think roberto should go for this
b6 plan it hasn't he's done it against
this is
and that's because you said that you
know he was a sign what is simon going
to tell me
not to do let me do that that's always
the way well
but i mean just play and i really don't
think alyssia should try anything
different she no she went
free last time okay it's a similar setup
isn't it this one
um i guess it's very saying but she is
getting good positions here
daniel and this is a good position to
start your comeback
and you know how this good position
would be best enjoyed
with some coffee which i'm going to grab
right now yeah i'll give you the wheel
for about 10 seconds
yeah no no worries so one thing i don't
really like what white's done here now
is that check with the bishop um because
the problem
white has if you look at the the bishops
on the light squares
in this kind of pawn structure white's
bishop is so much stronger than black's
bishop
of the same color because that light
squared bishop can
of whites is on the other side of the
pawns
black's light square bishop is stuck
behind the pawns in the middle
so this check i'm not so sure if it's
the right thing to do
from alicia not a bad position here
though certainly not a bad position
because she's got these two pawns
in the center of the position and now um
okay roberto is forcing the exchange
there
the danger with having these two pawns
in the center of the board though
is that they can get chipped at they can
get a little chipped
and that's exactly what roberto's doing
he's chipping at them
with the pawn on c5 the knight on c6 and
they could at some point become very
weak so
i have to say this is not as good as the
other
games which alicia has played from the
white side i'm worried
that those pawns in the center are are
just weak rather than strong
and you know the wrong piece has been
exchanged the light squared bishop as
well
yeah and yeah look at that pawn train
that knight on c3
white would kill for that knight to be
replaced with a pawn and often in these
positions you do see
as weird as it is 92 here might be
something to consider because the thing
is
and and if knight takes d4 and knight
takes c4 well you could choose between
c3 and knight takes b4 that c
puns overloaded so knight
she does it and i've been consistently
impressed with alessia's decision making
in some of these moments the problem
here
might be the move c takes d4 and perhaps
we could show this on the analysis board
the problem here if you just blindly
take all the pieces
and this shows the danger of tunnel
vision focusing too much on one thing
okay everything is fine i've taken on
deep oh knight takes c2
and that's a fork so roberto does place
he dixie for alessia we'll have to be
very careful here
yeah yeah it's uh this is
it's just the pity white doesn't have
that light square bishop you know it's
such a nice piece to have
in these positions and uh um
now what is the move to play this is the
question right i mean
if black has grabbed that pawn
a little bit of pressure on the c files
c2 is weak
so oh she did she played oh she fell she
does
it i jinxed her i think maybe she sighed
and wants queen c
whoa oh no oh well she's giving it a
little laugh there
[Music]
laugh it off get it out your system yeah
oh no she looks tight terrified there
roberto looks even more terrified even
though he's just won a queen
and he's giving himself a little massage
i'll pour over yesterday i feel for that
it's a tough match everyone blunders at
times so
and she gets the thumbs up then yeah
okay but she's gonna just the positivity
she's focused she's still
up nine points and it takes
it takes a lot of strength to remain
positive in a moment like this
definitely um i would have probably
thrown a mouse all the way from
charlotte to new york city by this point
but alessia gathering herself and
uh you know roberto yeah he's like did
this religious happen
yeah i i she needs to rebuild i mean
this is uh okay we've got 25 minutes
left of the segment my my fear would be
that in the free minute as time gets
quicker obviously
roberto who's scoring very quickly is
going to score quicker
so i think she needs to get a point or
two on the board in this five-minute
segment
um to have a chance for the rest of the
match i mean it's still a big gap
still 10 points in it so you know
there's always a chance
with a match like this but she can't
afford to do too many blunders like that
again in the future
uh yeah you know unfortunately it didn't
go well there
she's playing on which is i think
totally understandable and just to try
to drag that clock down
a little bit more and how can you
recover from that daniel i mean if
you're in this match and you just
blundered like that
and the score you're on a bad run i mean
you must sometimes have this daniel win
you know you just game after game things
are not going your way
but it certainly happens to me enough
but oh yeah
well first of all by the way roberto he
didn't blunder the queen back he gave it
up
to have an extra rook simplifying his
task that's perfectly
legitimate um you just have to you know
it's hard not to speak in cliches but i
remember having several experiences when
and this happens in tournaments i
remember the 2016 us championship the
worst tournament
i've ever played uh you know i lost the
first game to wesley so
uh who is not the most shameful person
to lose to but you know you lose one of
those games
like something is really wrong with me
and the way that i'm thinking about
positions like my brain is not working
and i would lose game after game after
game and at some point
i i sort of rethought the situation and
i said okay
i'm not gonna play a good tournament but
i'm determined to win
one game you know it's like the
goalkeeper's glory
you allow six goals how do the how do
how does a goalkeeper and i read this
somewhere motivate themselves
when when they've allowed three or four
goals it's all about
saving one goal it's not about the goals
they've allowed it's about the goals
that
they're not going to allow it's about
that one game-winning
goal they're going to save and i think
that's what alessia has to tell herself
it's not about the games
she's lost she's just about saving one
goal
yeah i i mean that's why i'm thinking
one win for her
would be fantastic i mean because that
would be like right way
get the win on the board it changes that
kind of
energy as well because you get this in
blitz when someone runs good
their confidence rises and they
basically want to own you
you know they want to stamp their
authority on you it's quite a cruel game
you know you want to
and and that happens when you can own
someone and to break out of that pattern
is hard to do oh look at this she's got
the helmet on she means
i like it what kind of helmet is that
i'm wondering
this is the war helmet oh so good what
is that helmet
is that any idea daniel
i'm not i should i don't know i didn't
come across this in any of my history
classes
is this like a viking helm i mean i
think it's it seems to be more like
she's from italy is it like a roman
maybe a roman
helmet possibly one thing i saw the
other day i watched the lawrence trent
match and i saw him
with his weight i don't know if anyone
saw that so he's playing he's playing
against
danny wrench and when he got a good
position he started working out with his
weights
maybe he's getting lessons of uh you
know greg greg there
absolutely you know with his weight
exercises but
is the helmet the magic magic missing
piece of the jigsaw that's good feel
good you know and that reminds me of uh
unrelated but in the basketball dumb
contest i remember one year dwight
howard
uh sort of a famous basketball player he
he pulled off his uniform and he had a
superman shirt underneath it and
he immediately got the dunk of the
contest so
you know sometimes it's it's all about
wishing and willing something into
existence
uh as alessia again handling the opening
very well here so
maybe that helmet paying dividends
already
yeah i mean she means business in the
game this is the game come on alyssia we
want you to get
something from this game there's only
now
20 minutes left in the five minute come
on just get something from it
the night magic so what i like though in
the chat hello to everyone on the twitch
chat
we're getting so many different versions
of what that what that hat is now
everyone's saying is it is it you know
what kind of hat is it and i'm kind of
intrigued now but uh
it could be many different things i
guess but we gotta ask alessia in the
post game interview
we'll have to we'll have to see um
so it does remind me like you know some
computer game where you get the magic
hat you put it on and suddenly you're
like
your strength the magic hat right raises
your strength
so far it looks all right i mean uh this
position
is pretty standard for for what the
opening is um
it's it's roughly even i think white's
generally got slightly easier game here
with the central pawns
and black has to be a little bit careful
of the light square bishop
trapped in behind the sea pawn so but
it's a normal position so far right
yeah totally and you know you see this
kind of structure from
several different openings and here
alessia playing b4
she's probably going to follow this up
with c5 we you mentioned the sign that
bishop on b7 is currently blunted by
no it's not going to d6 but it's funded
by the c6 pawn
and uh the one problem with this type of
approach
is this c4 square and here we see
roberto heading for c4 he's probably
going to put plan tonight there
and white is probably slightly better
here white's got control over that
square
he's going to deploy his bishop to b2
but alessia's position is very very
solid here
if i were her i would probably put a
knight on b6 and i would play c5
so i try to cover the c4 square and open
up that b7
bishop and basically just make small
improvements uh to the position let's
see how she handles this
okay i'm going to put my lucky hat on as
well here we go i actually meant to get
i've got a profile
i've got a profile which is the psycho
cowboy uh but i brought this hat and
it's not really a cowboy hat it's more
of like a rancher's hat from australia
but this is for black [__] i'm going to
join the alicia club now
can't you do it but you're right here
those squares on there
on the queen side whenever you make a
poor move you do give away certain
squares
and there are certain squares there
which white now has control of so
i i it could have backfired that idea
right daniel
possibly yeah no i agree
but i'm just too focused on the hat you
you're you're just slaying
you're just slaying it it's the psycho
yeah that's like a hellboy used to it
used to be my
my nickname on the like internet chess
club i don't know maybe you're too young
to play in the internet no i remember
no i grew up with it you grew up with it
the internet chess club was like the
origin
of online chess i remember psycho cowboy
you're a pretty unforgettable figure son
wow that's when i used to be able to
play blitz than the years got to me
occasionally but i mean this position
okay it's still on it's still game on
right i mean
we look at the structure there's one
problem
with black's pawn on c6 i guess here uh
daniel this would be
my main worry if i was black here how do
you you know
a long-term weakness in the position
yeah right and alessia has gotten rid of
that bishop which used to stand behind
it but
that's not necessarily a good thing here
we see d4 by robert so securing
central control if c5 then he'll
probably play t5 one idea for alessia
could be
play c5 and then go 95 and basically the
idea is
once that queen leaves c4 slam down the
board with c4
try to open the position up let the
position brief and she does play c5
i would go 95 for if i was celestia and
quickly go c4
save that time for this complicated
middle game some point you have to trust
your intuition 95 here
or a bishop f6 followed by 95.
she seems to be best when she's on the
offensive like she had done in a couple
of those games of e4
so i really like your idea of doing that
i guess bishop there
first of all is okay as long as she gets
a knight into the central
square and i love your idea of pushing
that sea pawn
and that that seems like a good good
move but
i was wondering if white could have
maybe taken on e6 sacrifice there but
okay now
knight e5 mustang for sure 95 and 64.
and i actually really like black's
position and there she goes and then
she's done it
good stuff will she continue with c4
though
because that could liberate all the
pieces right she gets that move in
very benoni like idea and it solves all
those weaknesses
and queen b5 is interesting i thought
about that but i don't think it stops
black if alicia can take
and still go c4 look at these pawns on
the queen side that could get very
dangerous for white very very quickly
for example
take six look at these connected passers
that v3 move is going to be devastating
yeah definitely and they can certainly
push out the board and she's done this
and she's played it brilliant
i love this attitude it's like proactive
to the hats
come on alyssia do it for the hats and
uh she is a minute and 20 seconds down
though
this is a problem she's gotta keep that
tempo up
with c4 very complex position very
complex
definitely i'm sure it's not last right
and maybe rook takes a five and then
try to go after these past puns by
getting behind them with rook a4
something seems off about that though i
mean it's such a hard decision to make
here for roberto
and he does take on a5 he's taking it
okay
so now black squad decide there's also
maybe c3 yeah there is
three okay but he's done exactly that
now what about knight d3 at the right
moment
maybe now because if you take it i come
in and i queen my pawn and i'm winning
you know yeah
so
maybe after the game we'll take a bit of
a closer look on the analysis but i
think you're right simon i think that
was the crusher
sending the hat energy sending the hat
energy there
the problem is white does have the pawn
as well right so yeah that b-pawn is
fast and f4 and set by roberto
sure forwards
indeed
white's forcing alicia to play a good
move here and she slayed it darling
could she be winning here this is
winning for sure look at that b-pod it's
path basically the red carpet is the
world
but will she win i mean okay she's got
only a minute left she's got a big
advantage surely here
her b pawn looking strong things looking
good but it's converting it okay
beautiful well done i wanna alyssia
wow this is a good she needs this win to
keep the matchup
really important game and i don't see a
single
idea for white i don't see a single
rookie one he's got to play rook a1
okay one b2 rook b1 hope for the best
yeah i mean even knight e2 to c3 there
was quite a nice little tactic in that
position
just uh i mean and alicia has enough
time
55 seconds will she play b2 this knight
you've
got c3 yeah she has to keep her cool can
still go wrong here
absolutely don't move the bishop because
then the knight is hanging
yeah b2 was very important in order to
protect the knight she does it
she plays
this is an absolute masterpiece stunning
takes d1
don't take the b1 rook take the d1 or
distract the other rook king e1 is
forced now
but it's a full rook down or king yeah
and rooksy one's coming anyway whatever
happens
rook c1 get the rook to see one and
you're gonna be
so much material up this is fantastic
this has been a great game
keep the hat on absolutely maybe i have
to keep my hats on now and he's resigned
and it was resigned
on hat power absolutely
she's not taking it off let me tell you
she is not taking that thing off
yeah so should i keep my hat on this is
the question i mean i don't know i might
have to come off soon i'm getting a
little bit hot
but okay one more day only 11 minutes
left in the five minute portion i went
by alessia
yeah amazing and let me just show really
really quickly that critical moment in
the game
um so basically this idea of taking and
going c4 that was critical
and then alessia exquisite play here
with knight to d3
you can't take that knight because the
rook is in charge of defending the
bishop but the pawn promotes
and so roberto was forced to play e5
takes the bishop and if roberto takes
the bishop then b2
beautiful position that knight blocking
the rook rook blocking the other rook in
the pawn is unstoppable
amazing win by alessia as she extends
her lead now uh
two ten points yeah it's such an
important one and uh
she now has the advantage of the white
pieces and she's getting she's getting
this opening again and i kind of like
what she's done here daniel because
in the last game she got in problems
against bishop b4 so she just played a3
to stop bishop b4 here which is a nice
safe way
and we get this normal structure it's
actually very like a french defense so
now
uh this this position after bishop e3 uh
probably a normal
french defenses kind of position even
mm-hmm
yeah and it's been going well for
alessia these these types of positions i
would just go bishop e2 in castle
yeah she's played it and the main the
main
reason i kind of even though i played
the french defense one of the reasons i
like
white's position so often in these
structures is that
you've got to look at pawn breaks
there's a very important thing in chess
and
black has all these pawn breaks on the
queen side but so what your king's not
on the queen side
so if black pushes on the queen side
your king's safe but white
always has this idea at some point of
playing f5
g4 f5 and if white can ever play this
f5 move you can open up the black king
so uh
i i think this is a good opening choice
but both players playing good
natural moves as well at the moment
indeed
queen to b6 another very typical french
but what is the battle revolver on here
simon you mentioned the idea of f5
that's what alessia is preparing
for black well black can play h5 we've
seen roberto do that before
uh that rook on h8 could stand to
benefit in the event of hg4 of course
the h12 opens
but the other idea for black is is
attacking that g4 one idea
you can actually take on d4 you can play
rook h3 and attack
indirectly the d4 bond by pressuring the
knight you could also
we can show this on the analysis board
this is an instructive and actually
quite typical idea
you could literally take on g4 a million
times and then have we blundered the
queen no
bishop now we have but bishop c speaking
of mouse slips
bishop c5 trades the queens off and
blacken's a very very solid end game and
in the
very end of that end game you could play
g5 striking and chipping away
a white's pawn train let's see see takes
d4 has watched that happen
see takes deport has been played that's
a very nice idea actually i mean i i
didn't consider that one and uh
it's a bishop c5 oh my oh and the rookie
one with h3 that knight is in trouble
g5 here also looks good yeah out there
yeah actually white's position is the
ship extended
barely rookie three is obviously the
threat
and g5 is going to be pretty devastating
i'm telling you
it's a great bounce back by roberto i
mean this is exactly what you need to do
you lose a game
do you let it get you did you let it
fest or do you just strike back and it
looks like he's played
very well in this game typical french
defense breaks
maybe even alicia's g4 is a little bit
premature you don't
you know if you're going to attack on
one area of the board you've got to make
sure you don't actually
weaken that area of the board and it
could have been better to
stabilize the center before playing g4
easy to say in hindsight though of
course right and i would go g5 here but
now b4
now if i were a lessee i would try my
best that's still not good and i think
then roberto might do that thing i
mentioned with taking everything on d4
and striking away with g5 breaking apart
white's pawn chain
but but alessia's first order of
priority is is to get rid of the tension
on this knight and with that tension
going on
it's extremely hard for white uh to make
anything happen
uh bishop f3 instead
yeah g5 looks jesus i love your g5 move
is
again we mentioned pawn breaks and when
you're playing the french defense
you have to know your pawn breaks the c5
f6 and g5
these are three ones you should learn
about when you learn any opening
what are your typical pawn breaks in the
in the middle part of the game so you
know what plans you're doing
and the whole point of this move is
white center now
we've talked about it the pawns in the
center they can be very strong but they
can also be incredibly fragile
and if you can just chip away at those
pawns the whole
whole center will just explode in
black's favor
because the white king here is clearly
in more danger than the black king
so you want to open up lines towards the
white king
but now if roberto terry is any further
than b4 is going to be very very strong
what you don't want to do if you're
black is something like this right you
don't want to nonchalantly
take twice on d4 because the pressure on
the knight evaporates
and then white is better equipped to
deal with the idea of g5 also
black's king you can't sleep on that
that king is not the safest piece in the
world
this is the last opportunity for roberto
to play g5 and
he's a french player he should be
playing this move quickly
i'm surprised he hasn't played g5 yet
yeah as daniel points out g5
great move you're just trying to get rid
of that
main white anchor point in the center of
the board the pawn on e5
the only one of the only pieces black's
not doing anything the one that daniel's
just noted there
can jump into life with devastating
effects
but because he hasn't found g5 yet he
hasn't played it again i just don't
think he's seen this idea
he's um moved his queen out the way a
little bit of uh
a backwards move giving alicia some hope
now g5 maybe for white now i mean i know
that looks that doesn't look great but
you might as well i mean to me to say
you have to prevent it at all costs
i guess you can also try this b4 move
again
maybe pray you get a rook over to c3 but
it it doesn't yeah i mean it's tricky
for alicia this position
she's played c3 g5 now is he's getting
stronger and stronger because now that
he is
it really is now look at these pieces of
train all of them
it's begging to be played but knight a5
is going the other way
i mean still it should be noted black's
got such pressure on white's position
that essentially anything keeps the
pressure and i'm not going to c4
where roberto's doing makes sense it's
just that g5
uh and i sound like a broken record but
g5 is really strong
i really like it and it also goes by the
principle that when you've castled
on opposite sides of the board then it's
all about the attack and the kings are
on opposite sides you've got to look at
your pawns
just throw them at your opponent's king
so it it basically goes with a lot of uh
it's the right move to play uh so
alyssia is still some hope here
um uh roberto doe is
is better in this position definitely
because black's plans are easier than
whites
oh without a doubt this is just so hard
to defend against i mean
yeah bishop f2 night coming to c4 and
uh you will never guess um what idea
i would propose after the queen moves i
don't think anybody in the chat will
ever be able to guess
okay i think it's g5 all right
i thought you were going to get ready to
sacrifice on e5 even oh he's played it
he's played it at last
oh and there we go and it's actually at
its strongest i think
with that knight on c4 now covering that
square and this just collapsing for a
lesson
they will get one more game in uh before
the five minute portion concludes
right so the match score obviously it's
still
a big lead it started with 15 point lead
so we're just trying to
i'm just trying to sort of do the maths
in my head and the mouse
there's three uh oh oh oh i'm sorry
that was one of each one
i'm gonna have to put my psycho cowboy
hat on at special moments i feel i don't
know i'd only use
up the energy too much um but the way
it's going if we think there's the five
minute section
three minute section and the one minute
section
it started at 15 nil to alicia that's
the handicap
and so you'd think if if roberto can get
five points every section then he will
catch up with alicia
that's the way but it doesn't always
work like that maybe it's tougher in the
bullet section but
the way my simple mind is working okay
you get a five point advantage or more
in every section you're gonna you're
gonna win the match
so it's exactly five points is it no
it's it's less now isn't it oh hang on
can i count
well it's a nine minute it's a it's a
nine points
uh match right now and they started with
15. so six points
has been made up for roberto with this
last game
going on yeah and they've come full
circle they've repeated
the line that that they played in the
very first game this
sort of queen's gamma declined isolated
deep on
positioning we see alessia playing in
very typical fashion night before
when you have an isolated queen spawn
aside playing against it
one of the most typical ideas as old as
the hills is to gain control of the
square
in front of the pun immobilizing that
pawn for white you want to be active and
that's exactly what roberto is doing you
can see him centralizing his knight
bishop bungie pipe i like what white is
doing but unless they're trying to
establish that blockade on the d5 square
yeah i mean this this isolated pawn
position it's kind of um
a lot to do with taste um i think that
most strong grandmasters prefer having
the isolated pawns of being
in white's position there's a couple of
simple rules to go by
if you're white with the isolate pawn
you want to keep pieces on the board
and attack your opponent's king because
that pawn gives you more opportunities
to do that
but when you're black in such a position
you want to try to swap off pieces
and try to prove later on in the ending
that white's pawn in the middle board is
actually weak
the reason it might be weak is that
white pawn in the middle of the board
it can't be defended ever by another
white pawn
so it's always going to be only defended
by white's pieces
but at the moment i really i think these
kind of positions are so much easier for
white to play
because all you do you just put your
pieces on good squares and you attack
black's king
and black has this problem with a bishop
on c8 how do you get this bishop into
the game
if you can't get that bishop in the game
it's tricky so knight d5 aiming for
exchanges
seems fairly logical yeah and it works
tactically because
if you try to ah if you say ah but the
knight defends the bishop i can just
take the knight
well black is not obliged to take on g5
black can take
the bishop on g5 and in general when
you've got a cramped position trades
favor to the side
playing against the iqp roberto instead
taking on e7
he chooses to preserve the light squared
bishop and now this knight
uh going to e4 perhaps heading to g5 or
to d6
i agree with the simon i think what
makes this hard to play for black is
this bishop on c8 if alessia can solve
that
from the bishop then she'll have a good
position but
without the queen side it's very very
tricky situation here for black
as also daniel rook a free is a very
tempting move just swing that rook over
you know
inside i mean this is the kind of
position where you're white you know
what to do you look at the black king
you attack it so you want to get every
piece into the attack and
i kind of like this like swinging rook
idea you know the swinger
i think um i think it was jennifer
shahad had called it
the rover the roaming rook was it but
the rover roaming rook but it's a nice
attacking idea
white's instead playing on the queen
side also uh a decent move to play right
yeah definitely and you got to be
careful about the about the queen if
black plays b6 this funny funny line
bishop takes d5
knight takes d5 knight c6 would trap the
queen
and uh just something that occurred to
me so oh
gosh don't tell me this is going to
happen oh no
i'll know you no no no i have a bad
feeling you know oh no
have this nickname that some people give
me no no it's not gonna
there's no way this is going to this is
i'm leaving
please take with upon alicia daniel
nostradamus naraditsky
right i'm leaving a few days with the
night oh no take with the pawn
oh no you're done daniel
i think i think you're forfeit you have
to go and find a hat
oh my god i can't believe it you found
the
main losing line and and
it's happened oh no i'm so sorry oh
jinxing jinxer oh my lance that's just
unbelievable but now
yeah that queen is trapped look at these
knights white black and try net f4 but
and she probably will but the queen can
go just about anywhere
yeah so what do your friends call you
did
nostradamus the prophet the prophets
and it comes from you know pogchamps one
when i
help prepare my student charlie who is
you know he's a big youtuber he was a
participant in pogchamps one and
he played this well-known game against
xqc
um you know another very very big twitch
streamer and we were able to predict a a
mate
in the scotch in the scotch game oh wow
and the game followed our line entirely
it wasn't
he was the one who decided to take the
risk so i
you know i got most of the credit which
i shouldn't have but
ever since then you know i've i've had
this nickname so i guess i have to live
up to it
so that's some good preparation there
daniel so yeah
very good preparation and um well okay
i mean there's not even any point
running down the clock here to be honest
because it's the end of the five minute
section
to let everyone know what happens next
well we're after
a break there's obviously the three
minute section and then the bullet
section so
do you think alicia can come back in the
three minutes section i mean this lead
is going to be quite she's still got a
lead but it's dropping quickly right
and uh i think she needs to get that
confidence back get a couple of wins in
the three-minute section really
two times oh yes definitely and
you know i i thought i saw that glimmer
of increased confidence in her play
especially surrounding that when
she put the hat on she got the mojo back
and there was something a little bit
crisper about her play but with three
minutes on the clock you can't afford to
take
those long things particularly in the
opening so she's gonna have to decide on
what she's playing
she's gonna have to tell herself i'm
trusting my intuition there's gonna be
blunders here and there but
if roberto repeats these dubious
openings with black alessia it's got
every chance to deliver another strike
with the white pieces so i'm gonna be
very very interested to see how they
modify their strategies going into the
three-minute portion and let's say i'm
playing this one out
but but uh it's just a full queen for a
piece
yeah i i know alyssia's i think her
boyfriend's a very strong chess player i
hope he's there ready to prepare her
because they're going to have a short
break and if i was you know if you were
alicia's second
and okay has gone now to that end i
would be like right okay let's hear
you're getting these positions that's
why
you know you're getting this kind of you
know this is your chance for the white
pieces just
try to keep that light square bishop on
the board go for the king
you know these little bits i think this
is their best chance with white pieces
in the next section
absolutely and we will let these players
have their pep talks and have their
moment to breathe
but all of the most interesting action
is still ahead we will bring you the
three plus one segment coming right up
first a very short break and when we
return
the i am not a gm speed chess
championship match between alessia
sanoramo and roberto junio
junio brito molina returns
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
i am not a gm speed chess championship
brought to you by chess.com
we have the three plus one segment in
this really awesome match between alicia
sanorama and roberto molina
coming right up but first uh what else
is coming right up of course
the long-awaited return of the pogchamps
pogchamps 3
and this is going to be absolutely
unmissable as popular streamers
xkc and ludwig make their
return and this is going to be an
absolutely insane lineup with
youtubers and very prominent twitch
streamers
and code miko joins the fields as the
first
uh i mean this is going to be absolutely
unbelievable
some of these names are mouth-watering
we've got the return of some this is
going to be invisible and it is coming
your way
in mid february but first
what else is coming your way the three
minute portion of this very exciting
match simon
what are your thoughts on how this match
has gone
as the players uh prepare to begin the
three-minute portion
um well first of all i think uh roberto
has played extremely well
i mean there's no doubt about that i
mean he started 15 points down
so he has to play top quality chess to
to make that gap much smaller he's done
that
if he keeps going the way he's going at
the rate he's winning he's going to win
this match i feel
there has been a lot of glimmers of hope
from alicia i mean she's played some
great chess
she won that really nice game with some
really crisp tactics and she's got to
remember that segment where she got that
attack in
and i think she's got to go for this
aggressive play
but in a way and this is a chance with
the white pieces this is where she's
getting good positions and
i this is this could be a very important
game we'll see now the pace is quicker
it's three minutes
but she's got knight to f3 okay so she's
changed her setup daniel slightly
yeah and the irano thing is the only
game alessia has won
has been to the black pieces when she
sees that chance but she's gotten these
these great positions in this line and
and is there a possibility that she did
some very very quick preparation in that
five minute break
possibly because in this position knight
bd2
would keep the tension on e4 there's
that fundamental choice does white go e5
and those are the kinds of structures
alessia has has gone
for or does white take okay so she takes
on d5 normally black takes with a queen
here as far as i remember
simon yeah i guess you can take the
queen or the knight here i mean this is
a totally different kind of pawn
structure
for what alicia has gone for before as
you mentioned that white pawn's normally
pushed up so
she's trying to change her strategy
she's going for more
open positions where there's more open
lines maybe giving her
more potential to attack and this is
certainly
there's nothing wrong with the way she's
playing here but i do like this move
queen h5 i mean this is good
aggressive play and in a quicker time
limit game you've got to ask yourself
which king
is under more danger and it had with
those lovely arrows you
drew there daniel there is some little
problems immediately with the white king
right because
black's queen is hovering around the
white king here
with some bishops that can increase the
firepower on white's king as well
i would consider 95 bailing out into
into a queenless metal game
and i'm feeling alessia's pain right now
because i myself i remember
getting into this particular type of
position a million times
when facing b6 you make some of these
nonchalant moves
you think you're just developing all of
a sudden black's piling up on on the
king's side here bishop d6 seems very
natural
another idea for alessia maybe put the
knight on e4 every trade here
lessens the load on the kings oh but be
careful because knight e4
takes takes and bishop takes h2 that's
a pretty scary idea as well so alessia
h3
but one thing black can consider at some
point is g5 g4 this pawn
is what we call a hook alessia very
careful though 94 like what she's doing
disarming the attack yeah i like this i
mean we mentioned in the other
structures where black has a pawn on d5
in the five minute section that black's
light square bishop was a bad piece
but in those positions black's light
square bishop was better than whites
and you've always got to trade off if
you have a bishop for a bishop just
think which bishop is stronger
if it's your opponents which it was
black's bishop and alicia has done this
very cleverly
she's just changed off that bishop she
also has a nice c6 square here daniel
maybe
yeah at some point the white queen can
drop into this square
it's just kind of like torches black
around there but
the first thing i do here is white is
just getting my bishop out finish my
development
maybe as you say push that c pawn uh and
it's it's probably roughly even this
structure
yeah but white's got a slight space
advantage so so far
so good for alicia but that time
situation
is very very concerning this isn't the
five minute portion anymore and unless
they're about to dip below a minute
13 moves in that's not a very
sustainable pace because
this position may seem very quiet but
it's kind of deceptive it's got a lot of
potential to transform
in a variety of ways and what roberto is
going to try to do even perhaps now is
go
c5 open the position up a little bit
maybe bring the rook in first keep the
tension
uh and and alessi needs that time to
prepare herself
for the position sharpening up a little
bit
uh but let's see how she handles this i
mean this is another
big issue with these kind of matches
you've got to bear in mind when you
change from one time limit to the other
when it gets quicker you need to
adapt the way you play and i don't think
alicia has adapted
to that change in time it was five
minutes now it's three minutes
three minutes is a lot shorter than five
minutes and she's already only got 45
seconds left so she's gonna have to
speed up here definitely 100 absolutely
and there we see it c5 and and this is
what i'm talking about now unless he has
to make this choice does she take on c5
bishop c3 is a very typical response
basically c takes c4964 almost reaches
this kind of karo khan like end game
uh where both sides have their
respective pawn majorities i don't think
roberto is going to go for an mdm like
this
um what should black do instead
something a queen f5 comes to mind
keeping the tension when your opponent
is in time pressure
one of the most effective strategies is
not to play particularly forcing chess
you know force your opponent to be the
one to continue making decisions
yeah i totally agree and i think with
this knight h7
black is simply keeping pieces on the
board and 30 seconds now
this knight coming around to f4 is that
the idea so
i think it is keeping all the pieces on
the board alicia now
playing quicker yeah or maybe even
bishop b5 get some pieces off and uh
keep the position as simple as you can
that one is weak it is weak she's
speeding up but
she might be losing that pawn somehow
here yeah or just f6 is even stronger
than doubling
yeah and there we have it the position
transforms
so hard to adjust dynamically and
alessia has to drop her knife back c5
wouldn't work because if bishop takes c5
yeah this is this has gone wrong i mean
especially with 11 seconds left i mean
she's got to learn from this one
i'm not sure if our opening choice to be
brutally honest
was a good idea i mean she got an okay
position
she was getting okay positions in the
five minute segment so why
change when you you're getting these
positions which are okay
and she could be probably losing another
game here
it's only going to be as what's it seven
point difference in score
and there's a lot of time left there's
40 minutes in this segment
and then the bullet section she needs to
get that hat back on daniel the laptop i
agree
that hat that have brought her a win in
the five-minute portion
i might have to get my i might have to
get my hat on just to give that energy
again now
and is that when he put winnie the pooh
in the background of a video it looks a
bit like winnie the pooh it does it does
get all the mascots in the picture as
well
and i gotta say go ahead i was gonna say
is there any hope in this position for
her not with the time i think
yeah it's it's really a matter of time
before
you know you blunder it doesn't matter
if you're magnus carlsen or
whoever you are you know in four seconds
on the clock and unless he's doing a
very very admirable job she's acquitting
herself extremely well in time for so
comparatively speaking
the problem is you know the game drags
on eventually you're going to reach a
situation where
you have to make a decision too fast and
here we see dropping another pawn
this is a technical win now for roberto
who himself has plenty of time
i agree with you simon i i think it's
easy to psych yourself out when you keep
losing in a particular
variation but alessia's got to focus on
the positive she's getting great
positions out of that f3 system
um i think she's got to keep repeating
that but
trying her best here i don't think black
too
i don't think roberto got in too much
trouble in this this opening i mean okay
alyssia was maybe slightly better at
some point
and she played some good moves but it
wasn't the pressure she was getting in
the five-minute section so
i wouldn't i if i you know i wouldn't be
repeating this opening for her
she's doing well though to drag this
game on i thought it'd be over by now
just because of her time
yeah london no this is not roberto
missed a chance i believe to win a piece
there i'll show that after the game
but yeah that bishop now finding a
stronghold on g5
and that king on g6 is sort of entombed
you know roberto doesn't want to leave
that g7 pawn hanging
he's trying to finagle his way around
but knight d4 before at some point is
gonna have to be played but
wait a minute oh my god it's a draw it's
a draw
defeated repeated moves
unbelievable unbelievable
in an accidental repetition and you
could just see him roll i mean
wow wow i think they're both in shock i
mean they're really roberto's in shot
but look at lydia she's like
draw where where where's the draw yeah
exactly and unbelievable really really
quickly
i'm showing that moment when you could
have won a piece sorry not to interrupt
you sam
just in this position knight to b5 easy
to miss but opening up the attack on the
rook and exposing the attack on the
night neither piece
can't do anything about that that would
have won on the spot incredible
incredible stuff
what a save by alessia yeah i mean
that's the kind of thing you need in the
match like this you need that little bit
i wouldn't say luck because she defended
amazingly there
that showed really resilient and i
didn't expect her to hold
that one with her time situation as well
and uh very positive uh and we're back
now into a position
where how's roberto going to react to
that that's the other thing is roberto
going to be like
ah i'm so annoyed i'm gonna crow oh
it looks scary oh no this is already
almost lost for black
yeah this this is this is a bad opening
choice right out of the gates
i mean look at the pressure the rook
x-ray and the queen that bishop on e7 is
dangling
this is horrific for black even though
the center is open don't be fooled by
that
there don't have to be pawns for the
position to be bad yeah
i mean that that was quite funny when we
saw the draw in the last game
obviously we're missing over the board
play and i hope lots of you are
now maybe new to chess watching this in
twitch you
become brave when covid's gone and
dusted and you join your local
tournament you give it a go something
like that but it reminds me a funny
story daniel that
i was next to a grand master and he was
uh english grandmaster his opponent
it was a young junior who was about 400
points low rate of them
and he offered him a draw you know the
junior offers the geometry or the
yeah the junior offers the gm a draw in
a position where he's a bit worse
and the the gm just looks at him and he
says
he just shakes his head and he just and
you know it's just that look i remember
that look it's like
ah you should not be offering me a
drawer i'm a grand master
i just said it something like that and
there's funny drawers i remember another
time
when someone offered a grandmaster drawn
the grandmaster just stood up
and he looked around he said where
where's the drawer
this is a good one where's the draw um
have you ever been offered like a rude
draw
at any point because obviously in chess
your opponent can offer you a draw
but it's a little bit rude to keep
offering draws or offer a draw in a very
bad situation
so no 100 percent i i have and um
i remember and i have a story that i've
shared on my stream
uh and and this was my first scholastic
to my first nationals in in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
i think the first time i've ever been on
a plane and i remember this was a big
deal this was like i was
i think in third grade my rating was
about you know it was about a thousand
so i knew what i was doing for the most
part
uh and i think in the third round i'm
playing a kid
and and i remember it was a fried liver
i was playing with white pieces
and uh eventually we reach a position
where i could have
shifted my queen he threatened checkmate
and i could have
defended against the checkmate while
pinning and winning his night
uh and i missed that move and instead i
defended against the checkmate with a
pawn
and as soon as i made the move i started
kicking him i kind of won his knight
but guess what he does this kid he was
trying to pull some shenanigans on me
and he says
you touched your queen and the reason it
said that is because he thought
that by moving the queen i would have to
walk into checkmate
and uh instead of disputing it i said
yeah i did move the queen i did touch
the queen so instead i ended up
retracting my night move and making the
correct queen move
defending against the mate and winning
his peace of course he started crying at
that point
and he called over the arbiter hey he
told me i moved the queen
so i moved it and at the end of the game
he started offering me draws on every
single move
and i felt bad of course he was i
remember he was crying and you know that
just happens in scholastic tournaments
but
uh anyways it was like i had a rook a
bishop in six pawns against a rook
and he was making a move and did you
just look at me
as much of a merciless heartless killer
as i am now
i don't believe that i don't believe
that i do i can remember a story
similar to that when i was a junior i
won't mention the name but i was playing
against um
miguel in a competition and we're trying
to qualify for the british squad under
11 championships
uh for the team so some you know british
squad thing and
this game was a very important game the
last game going on and she was known to
be a very good player she went on to
become
women women's world champion of one of
the age groups and i i was i was beating
her
but i think i quite liked her and she
she started crying
and she started crying and i was like oh
you know i was like
and i just i just said do you want to
draw and she and she
whipped my hand off and all of a sudden
the the tears just stopped
and it was like i was like and i learned
a lot a lot of lessons about women at
that moment no i didn't really but
it was like literally it was like bang
stop crying yep draw and she got on the
team and i didn't and i was like
probably should and you know you've got
to be nasty in chess right you've got to
be nasty you've got to go for the win
right
no matter who you're playing so uh
anyway back to the game here and
it looks like alicia is is doing okay
con considering the opening that
she's mounting some counter play
absolutely
we're too nice oh and but she blooded
why did he jingle rick takes d6 that
blender's a bishop oh no
a blunders bishop and just like in the
story you make the move and you defend
the other piece
yeah yeah and that unfortunately i mean
that was just a very tough position to
sustain for a long amount of time
yeah well yeah i mean she did well to
get to that situation
and now the score i mean okay i did say
she was going to lose the last one so
but this is a whole piece right i mean
this is this is massive
and your king is in a bad situation as
well
so um it's the conclusion to the story
did you at least you know
go out after the game or well i mean at
the time
still at the time i was only like 10 or
11. oh
yeah okay it's one of those little
crushes but
maybe years later maybe years later i
might have and then 30 years later you
reunited
in a bar somewhere
[Laughter]
unfortunately that's only in novels yeah
well
yes um it was yeah it's one of those
things you've got you've got to learn to
be a bit ruthless when you're yeah
no that's true it's just one it is a
game it's a sport and
i think you you learn that and you
realize that the board you put the
emotions aside right
so on those things to do and i think you
know even though it's it's natural to
you know especially when you're a kid to
cry after losses you never really blame
your opponent for being
for being ruthless for trying everything
they can and the tears are more
sadness on your end and i remember
you know and i was i think i was 11 and
i was playing my good friend sam
shankland
and we were playing a tournament
deciding game
and i blunder in the opening and i could
just
you know and i hated displaying i still
try not to display any emotion of the
board
but i could just feel you know your eyes
just welling up
and i can feel the bile rising in my
throat and i just i could not stop
myself
i mean he had to go get me like a
kleenex because like and and sam tells
the story very well but sometimes you
just can't stop yourself
but i felt so bad putting him in that
situation
so yeah anyway i mean they do say though
that
when you're a kid if you don't cry after
a loss
then you're probably never going to make
it it's that's true it's the kids who
cry
it means a lot too who are going to
become the grand masters because
they get so affected by it they bounce
back and they treat it so seriously so
it's actually a good thing to cry
as as it is as a kid you know um
no it shows that you care it's a very
natural response and i i there's nothing
wrong with that i mean i think
i tell some parents of my students that
you know i
cried all the time after i lose i think
it's you know the kids who care
they they put so much emotions into the
game that
uh it's weird if they don't cry after a
loss
yeah i agree so i mean now okay so the
seven
points by the looks of it if i can count
in the match
at the moment and uh we're back now to
this opening which
roberto keeps playing and he's got this
knight b4
and this is kind of known to be quite a
a move that white maybe
should stop is that right it's fair to
say i mean it's still okay
totally okay for one yeah white's got
the center and white can push d5
but yeah i would i would push d5
asap yeah
okay but preparing that one but now but
now black yeah
now black is a little bit freer yeah
so probably a fairly even position both
sides quite solid white has
the the central advantage a little bit
but
black has the two bishops black is solid
black can play along the c
file and without a light square bishop
the problem is the reason again
if we look at white's position without a
light square bishop it's so hard to
attack black's king
because you need that light square
bishop you know on the diagonal pointing
towards h7
without i you know in this last move i
don't like positionally
because you're opening up black's bishop
but you're closing your bishop maybe
tactically white's going to get some
chances with the knight coming in but
seems a bit risky i agree black's
getting so many
and now you're gonna have a very classic
situation about good bishop it's a bad
night look at that monster
and by the way roberto can take on g5 as
well get the two bishops but
even taking on d5 is very simple and
very strong
i mean in the event of something like
this look at this monster sitting there
on t5 controlling the long diagonal this
knight on f3
it's not that it's that bad but it
doesn't have nearly the same prospects
that that bishop does and roberto does
play it simple
uh and rightly so big time domination
here for black
yeah it's this move you can think of
that pawn
on the dark squares that alicia moved
it's just released
the remaining bishop that black has and
you have to be careful
about that your opponent's bishop and
now black has the open c
file and this is this is going from bad
to worse this position
at the moment i mean how does white get
counter played do you try to get your
knight in
e4 knight f6 some desperado attack
might be called for but i don't see it
working you know really
i mean uh i would probably try that when
you've got a bad position just go for it
right and i like this move h6 very
level-headed making some luft for the
king
uh i would consider at some point taking
on e5 maybe employing that other rook
trying to get it to c3 but you know
these positions are just so
so tough to defend queen to g5 is
another idea
uh sometimes people forget that an
endgame could offer
uh more chances in such a position
because the queen is really
the glue piece but roberto going for
rook dc that makes perfect sense as well
94 i would try totally you got to try
94. i think there we go
roll the dice and this is a good
practical choice here because now the
rook can come to g4
if you get a move you know if it's
white's move rook g4
some frets all of a sudden i don't know
that bishop takes c4 that was really
hasty i think it was i mean the you you
said how strong the the blacks bishop
was it was much better than a knight
so why exchange the bishop off i agree
uh this is not so bad maybe for white
now
no i don't know can fight back here this
is e3 and she
she's displayed iron clad resilience
throughout the mat i mean she just
doesn't give up she finds these
these annoying little resources and i
mean that in the best possible way 94 is
an annoying move
and uh i think roberto just took a
little too quickly without under
evaluating fully the
you know the consequences of it i mean
she's a real fighter
and she's she's coming with these tough
moves and
this is the position where i'd like to
have played rugby for there i don't
really want to go into an ending um
uh this situation it's still still a bit
better for black because i think black
pieces are better centralized right here
and and b4 c3 and other
so go ahead no i i i think it's
it's still better isn't it for black i
mean uh
yeah the pieces it's all about the
pieces here and white's pieces
need to get in the game maybe queen a8
queen e4 trying to get to an ending
is something now that alicia should do
just but you're going to lose f2
particularly now though because now you
would win that v4 pawn at the end
yeah go for the ending go i mean
sometimes the ending is
is a place where you can be saved right
uh if you've got a bad position you can
liquidate into an
ending just try to swap everything off
in the ending and hold the draw is she
going to go for this
no she's come back to her free this is
also a decent way to play right
yeah because she's attacking up seven
and if i were roberto i would
i would i mean if you play rook c okay
rook c3
that's an actually pretty good move
because the queen end game doesn't
guarantee a draw if you take on f7
what's going to end up happening is
actually this might be a drop because
here
you have this key move queen back to f4
let's see how alessia plays this you
certainly don't want to take that rook
in queen end games the worst thing to do
is give your opponent a far advanced
pass spawn
so whatever you do you want to keep this
rock on a3 make this b3 pawn
as hard to capture as possible
let's let's keep an eye on the clock as
well i mean this is something that's
been
a little bit of a problem for alicia and
i just like this simple movie taken on
f7 you know
if there's not a reason to grab a pawn
grab a pawn yeah
you should always do that just grab any
pawn you can see unless you get
chipmated right
or lose material oh that's horrible and
that's not good i think allison missed
that queen f4 idea i think she just
spent it
roberto can even take on e5 here but
that would not actually be
good yeah you want to take here and it's
over
in alyssia panics unfortunately yeah and
the problem with queen endings
is that it doesn't even matter if you're
pawn up
or pawns up sometimes it's who's got the
more dangerous pawn and you can see
black's pawn is
two squares away from queening because
alicia decided to allow it to move to
that square so
yeah she she fought back so well as well
this is kind of the frustrating thing
daniel
she sometimes getting bad positions
fighting back
and then dropping it again you know
which is which is hard
but here there's no perpetual no
professionals available
so yup that queen on t2 doing a hero's
duty and
just to show us roberto puts the
finishing touches on the game
that key moment when alessia could have
held the game uh
and the rest will be quite simple here
but just to rewind queen takes f7
was the key move and what we saw is okay
rook takes c3
and i think alessia was deterred by this
position it looks like ah there's a fork
black wins e3
but no queen and sorry but that queen
just comes back to f4
uh offering the queen train and the pawn
end game is just a dead draw white king
comes out
just in time so big chance there by
alessia is still a very good fight
takes a big chunk of time off of the
match clock
but at the end of the day um at the end
of the day
that's a win for roberto and we will
take that short halftime break
as the lead shrinks to six points and
when we come back
the second half of the three minute
portion in this fascinating
i am not a gm speed chess championship
match
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
second half
of this three minute portion of the i am
not agm speedchest championship brought
to you by chess.com we are in the midst
of what has been an amazing match
between women's fm
alicia sanoramo and international master
roberto molina it's been
a match that has gone roberto molina's
way so far as alessia has only managed
one win
but we remind you that alessia started
with a 15-point head start she scored
one scintillating victory and right now
uh alessia's lead stands at six points
with approximately 20 minutes left in
the three minute portion that will be
followed by
i believe 25 minutes of bullet as they
are about to get underway simon
your thoughts on how the match has gone
so far and uh now i'm gonna put you on
the spot
your predictions for how the rest of the
match is going to go
uh well so far i mean roberto has been
very impressive
um you know we could concentrate on
alicia's play which i think is being
positive but just missing a lit you know
a little bit but it's tough when you're
playing
someone he doesn't really make mistakes
roberto hasn't blunted he's defended
well
he's kept the pressure on he's moved
quickly and
the way things are going he's going to
win the match unless
something changes just at this rate
because
he's only now six points off and there's
a lot of games to go
so something needs to change for alicia
to get back into this match
and she needs to get that hat back on
get another win
this opening is also i'm not sure this
is a good choice as black
personally because it's very easy for
white to play
uh and attack i mean one very known idea
here is to swing the queen over to h4
i remember kramnik playing uh ex-world
champion kramnik playing this idea of a
rook on d1 but
uh we'll have to wait and see daniel how
do you think it's gonna go
well i i contended before the match and
i sort of agree with you that if
roberto manages to bring this to five
points or less
he's got to be the heavy favorite in
bullet i remember him playing bullet as
early as the icc days under the same
handle
a roberto jbm and you know experience
really shows
in in bullets so i i agree with you
alessia's gotta make some tweaks here
and and she's gotta turn things around
she's got 20 minutes to do so
and to me the reason that this is not
the most suitable opening choice isn't
because it's bad
but it's because from what i've noticed
alessia is extremely good her strength
is playing with the initiative and that
means open positions
unbalanced positions she's able to find
a very strong resources quickly the
problem with this position
is it's kind of a key g sort of you got
to be able to play
cramped and you got to be able to defuse
various
uh tactical chances by by white and that
just doesn't seem to be
quite up her alley with that being said
in this game
she's got the early time advantage and
it seems that she's gotten quite the
good
version of this iqp position we remind
you night before the idea is to bring
under control the square
in front of the isolated queen's pawn in
order to prevent
and we've already seen roberto do this
once a move like d5 which i think he's
calculating he's probably deciding
whether to play d5 or whether to play a
move like 95 improving his position
yeah i agree i mean at least this time
we saw in this opening previously that
alicia
wasn't able to get her light square
bishop into the game
and now that bishop has a very nice
square if he can get to c6 so it's an
improvement
uh my problem with playing this opening
for black is that in blitz the quicker
i find at least personally the time
limit gets the more important is to
have the initiative and the problem with
this opening is black
you are kind of defending white always
gets the initiative
in this isolated pawn position so it's
it's harder to play for black you've got
to be more accurate
but roberto now has given up one of his
bishops and he's got to prove
why he's done that in in this in this
structure because you don't
really want to give your bishops up like
that unless there's a real reason i'm
not sure
i would have captured on f6 there daniel
is there is there a point behind white's
play
yeah i'm on the same page and i think
roberto is realizing that
as he's dipping almost below a minute
maybe knight c5 here
really the only justification to me
would be some sort of
very concrete play connected with d5 i
don't really see that being particularly
effective and we see knight c5 here
alessia's ideal setup would of course be
a bishop on c6 and a knight on d5 that
would be
ironclad blockade on that square
we talked about that the problem is of
course for her if she goes knight to d5
and the knight is hanging
uh roberto is going to snap that knight
off the board and that transformation of
the pawn structure is going to be
beneficial for
for white not to mention the fact that
b7 is hanging
so let's see it takes on c5 but now ah
and that's a beautiful idea look at this
look at this very nice where is it
tactical really
really nice does this wonder a knight no
it doesn't because that rook on d1 would
have been hanging
and black is up the exchange the bishop
is protected by the queen
this forces prepare tonight to go into
an end game upon down this is a big
chance for alessia
well neither i don't think i don't well
i didn't see that tactic i'm not sure
daniel saw it but
i grabbing the pawn playing a brilliant
move this is what she needs to do
pray break play bravely and take
take her chances and yep she's now a
porn up and this is
good this is a great opportunity for her
i mean it's not simple
because white has control and bishop
yeah watch out
oh oh no but it's selective oh but then
still bishop takes e6 that is a
miss by alessia but still black is doing
okay here she's just got to make the
right decision in this position i would
try to
prioritize the b7 pawn over the e6 pawn
yeah that's a pity that white's got this
rook into d7 because
the there's a threat to two pawns
white's gonna win the
okay this is the only way to defend the
poor now very passive looks
yeah very passive defenses maybe
maybe a4 is worth trying right tracks
and then rook 84
try to open up the floodgates a little
bit but black's pieces are so bad
here yes you're a porn up but if you
don't you don't ever want to play chess
without a plan you should always try to
have
some kind of way to improve your
structure you can see white here
has a way to bring the king in the king
a very important piece in the ending
and what is black doing black's
struggling to find a good plan this this
is a real problem with the position
and roberto is he's i notice he's so
good at squeezing these positions look
at him advancing the pawn
he's making all the necessary
improvements in his position first black
might end up in some sort of a zugzwang
and ultimately white has several ways to
tighten the screws further i mean he
could bring the bishop to e4
and attack b7 he could try to double
rooks on the seventh
he's probably going to play g5 on the
next move in order to freeze up
black's pawns on the king side it's
going to be a case of two pawns holding
back three pawns very effectively
yeah it's i mean it's not the end of the
world for black because obviously black
does have that extra pawn
but um you can't escape from kind of the
prison or the back rank black's piece is
all tied down
and white can just sort of wait until
the ideal opportunity to
push the right pawn on the king's side
or try to grab a pawn if white
ever wins a pawn back then black is in
serious serious trouble saying that
you've got to break down defense
time again working against alicia here
she plays
now this i like it but maybe b4 yeah
okay can but now rook t3 would win that
pawn
and you know that rook on d7 is is
enough
for but b6 wait a sec oh
oh my goodness wait a minute knight c6
she's
she's she's jumping out now they're both
shorter times
she's got something he's got that pawn
that a pawn's got a long way up the
board this is
her position has improved definitely two
seconds now oh my god
[Music]
knight c6 is a good move rook takes b7
doesn't work
he's taking it but that liberates black
completely okay
i know alicia's better
got to make moves now brilliant moves
quick amazing
b3 though that rook on a4 now doubling
rook d6 is coming
rook a6 rook takes c6 rook takes before
oh
but that pawn oh and once again
simon that's heartbreaking but we see
this narrative alessia
climbing back against all odds but then
in time pressure
just not quite withstanding the pressure
yeah it's quite sad to see because she's
playing really well i mean she she's
she's fighting so hard she gets her kind
of maybe gets a little bit of a
trickier position to play out the
opening and then she finds the resources
she gets back into the game but her
clock
is playing against her and you can see
white's pawns are just far too advanced
here
uh it's an easy win for white but it's
it's a pity because she's getting
chances
but she's just not getting enough time
to take those chances unfortunately
so and it just seems that in those time
scrambles roberto is more experienced
as as we discussed he's a good bullet
player and
chess is a cruel game it's it's composed
of these small
moments you you go wrong in one two
moments and and the game is lost and
now the lead brought down even even
further
so five points yeah she played so well
to bounce back there
it seemed to me like when she plays
naturally without thinking like she did
when she was under a little bit of
pressure she plays really well so i
think it's something hold her
back in that last one she was sort of
had to play quickly
and she she turned the game on its head
she actually got an advantage
so maybe she just needs to play at a
tempo
pick up the pace here and just just go
for it now you know there's nothing to
lose
get your pieces in okay she's keeping
peace on the ball we've seen this
opening before
pretty pretty even i would say but white
does have the space advantage
she she needs she needs this one right
she needs this win
with only two days she really does the
white piece she's got a nice position
here
roberto deciding to take with a knight
on d5 earlier he had taken to the queen
a bit of a cryptic decision is now but
now he's going to get e5
in and alessia taking her foot off the
gas pedal here
c5 is also good rook d1 i would bring
the
the pieces into the game but yeah this
is a
i wouldn't i mean obviously it's not a
must-win in the strict sense
but you know if this gets down to three
points uh before the bullet you just
you know yeah you start thinking that
roberto becomes a very very heavy
favorite so
let's see how this is handled like you
mentioned roberto bullet
he's got a history of bullet he's he's
very strong anyway he's playing well
uh and you've got to think that this
year is going to be really up against it
in that segment so
she needs to she's at least coming
forwards now
she's still playing good chess here but
she needs to do something
to get a victory she does an ip5 a
bishop v8 that's a nice little move
disarming the knight and then you can
play a6 later if necessary
one thing i do like is her tempo has
quickened here so she's playing
playing a much much speedier than she
was which
which is a good sign so she is playing
natural and she's playing well
at the moment uh black's very solid at
the same time all the black's piece is
nicely centralized
in white with their last move trying to
double rooks on the open file which is a
normal idea to do
um and now an interesting decision there
black exchanges off
with this crafty night maneuver daniel
yeah and we've actually seen
a similar idea what roberto's going to
do i think is it we can show this on the
analysis board
he's going to go a6 and i think he's
going to put that queen on c7 that's
going to be a weird double attack
where knight f3 and queen h2 is going to
be a mate threat
oh that's something really to be on
there
watch out for because you could defend
c4 without seeing that
oh don't get queen h2 checkmate oh that
would be
ridiculous then i'm definitely leaving
if that actually happens
it's the kind of trick that's very easy
to miss it really is you
you know you could show that on the
board daniel because he might just play
bishop b3 in that last
yeah or c5 yeah and oh boom you know
it's tunnel vision you look at this fire
this boom
and that double power the queen of
bishop striking in
oh no and rook takes c4 now is the
threat if bishop b3 then rook d4 knight
f3 is going to follow always he's got to
see it
but it's actually bad for white well
maybe bishop f4
you have to try something here just be
careful that queen and bishop
are so so strongly played they should be
rook d4
this would be horrible with the end the
same tactic as we just saw
you can't play knight and free as black
here because of the white knight taking
it but you get rid of white's defender
and then you play the knight in
unleashing the queen so alyssia has got
a really hard decision to see by looks
of her
body language i think she's seen the
phrase she sees it and the main threat's
not taking the pawn the main threat
as daniel has pointed out is rook takes
knight
ah yes and then this one again
she's seen it very nice okay good move
she had to play this move
she's found the only defense welled done
the problem is queen takes c4
i'm probably miscalculating this ah so
take a look at this and we can show this
this is very instructive so
we get this mass trade and you might
calculate here ah the knight on d4
is hanging but guess what this is the
importance of calculating just one step
ahead knight c6 comes in that's a dagger
because it forks the rook and the bishop
so that works out for white
and roberto going that f3 anyway that's
a good level-headed response seeing that
line
we're gonna get some sort of an
opposite-colored bishop end game
and uh white's not worse there i have to
say alessia has
acquitted herself brilliantly here she's
done really well there was so many ways
she could have gone wrong
in the position and lots of tricks but
she's now doing okay this should be
roughly even if anything
you'd probably take white because in the
ending it's often who's got the easier
chance of getting a past
pawn that they can make a queen and
white's sea pawn
has that potential at some point to come
on but with that last move
black activating the knight that's a
very clever move
yet again by roberto he's playing very
good chess at the moment he is and
i would have gone bishop a4 with alyssia
if i were her and and tried to stick a
knight on c6 get that initiative before
black plans tonight anymore now it's
it's amazingly very hard to defend
against against these
weird night jumps unless you're trying
her best but that creates its own
weaknesses
and i would drop the bishop to g5 and
then perhaps to f6
in the event of h4 yeah and now an ic3
is a threat followed by bishop takes d4
and a fork on e2
yeah there's still some tactics here
rook f2e1 maybe
but look at the time again yeah this is
going to be an unsustainable here
yeah i mean this is the place if you
find your way through some early tactics
it tanks a lot of time
and that will pay later on in the game
and this is something
which as you can see from the the facial
reaction there
is a slight problem it's it's killing
her unfortunately she's
she's making good decisions the middle
game but then the game liquidates or
reaches a complex stage and with 10
seconds it's just impossible to monitor
all the tactics
but roberto took all credit to him yeah
he's doing a great job
definitely he certainly certainly to me
daniel looks like
a guy who could go very far in this
competition i mean
he's playing calmly he hasn't shown any
nerves he's quick
he's kept the pressure on he's never
really been in too much danger
right of losing he's lost the odd game
or you know the odd game
uh but he's he's really been impressive
so far
absolutely and he you know you might
look at the games hey he's
is he really doing anything brilliant he
might not be doing anything brilliant
but in matches like these it's all about
consistency he's shown
versatility ability to play different
kinds of positions he's defended very
well
he's conducted the initiative very well
and uh his positional understanding has
been consistently impressive these iqp
positions
uh it takes a lot of skill to handle
those quite as well as he has and
he knows how to push you know he he will
lose some advantages but but he keeps as
you said he keeps us calm
and he's able to layer on the pressure
even when he's
let go of some of the advantage yeah i
mean
he knows where to put his pieces and
that's what chess is about sometimes you
can see
even when he's short of time he has that
natural feel he's
creating problems creating problems
spotting tactical ideas
and he's just keeping the pressure on
alicia and uh
now the gap shortens yet again
and there's only five minutes left this
could be the last game there's still a
chance
let's not give up on this here yet
there's a one minute section after this
she is in the lead in the match
come on unless yeah so i get the hat
back on
he needs to get a win now okay every
time i've won the hatch he gets a win
we've got to put it back on
got to go back on crocodile dundee style
rather than a cowboy style i think come
on for a win for alicia to get the match
into the last stage give her a chance b4
again
this is kind of like a normal opening
and uh this b4 is a clever idea right
again
very clever but i think problems i
actually do think the black can take
and there's some complicated lines and
then you can go b5 and oh wow
wow that's diagonal but unless you're
going
to five which also seems very sensible
white's pawns become really really weak
and this is exactly the kinds of
positions that she wants to get
open and and she has the initiative but
roberto has been so good
at keeping his composure in precisely
these types of positions
but the hat for the win the hat for the
black for the win
nothing against roberto but i want
alicia to be in there
with the last part of the match so it's
kind of a close match this is the
position where
you can think about going h5 if you're
or you can just
play something sensible is that free
pawn the hat for the win
the hat for the win come on up castles
and black is up a pun
for no compensation come on the hat for
the win
white's queen side is in shambles bishop
d4 is an idea queen f6 i mean this
position
caught a whole ninety-five ninety-four
bishop f5 this might just collapse
forward
and just just to be clear you know we're
never rooting for one player or the
other but we want the match to be close
and you know it's
it's always more fun that way bishop at
least had a very interesting [__] bishop
f5 in this position
let's just show that quickly wow hard to
see
but b5 traps the queen oh oh that's a
lovely tactics
very nice oh g5
get that knight out of there and a
fourth something like this anyways where
alicia has played this perfectly well
she's winning here she's winning i mean
look at her pieces
all her pieces are just dominance look
at the bar the hat for the win
oh my goodness b5 wins the wins material
b5
material b5 is a lovely idea has she
played
92 knight c4 what's the queen
ninety-four will she fight it or knight
c2 wins the rook which one's it gonna
be is going to be a queen trapped if she
goes knight c4
she's got two minutes left come on he's
got plenty of time to think about
oh look at this line knight c4 queen
takes it and now kaboom oops sorry not
bishop of five of bishop c8
perhaps the queen look at that beautiful
way to attract that queen what a movie
will unless you see it she's got plenty
of time she has to get this one this is
a golden opportunity
she has to win this game i had simon
that has it's a hat for the win i'll
tell you
knight c2 is also a movie okay
it should be good enough it should be
good enough but i'm a little bit worried
knight c4 was ending it immediately yeah
i agree
you want to you've got to take your
opportunities and she's gone another
decent move don't miss h3 though
h3 is a threat that i don't have to be
less safe than it appears
queen okay bishop d4 could be coming
she's relying on some tactics here
she's still winning she's still winning
but the advantage is just slipping a
little bit it is she's down on time
if she lose this one
oh no no she's moved her queen into the
line of the bishop
oh okay
and you can see that oh that that hurts
physically hurt oh and now things are
collapsing oh
no no no
ah this has gone wrong i mean like
you're losing you've got so many pieces
on pre
here you gotta move the bishop though
get that knife move the bishop to f5
okay save the villagers
she's she's played it okay that's the
only move that's the only move to keep
in the game because
all her advantage is gone she's still in
the game
which she's got under a minute it should
be three though bishop d3 she's still
doing well i think she's still doing
one queen c2 no she is we can see that
on the bar i mean
she's got that initiative for the piece
it's clearly full compensation that
knight might not be getting out of there
the problem is the time again simon it's
that clock
it takes down on her and then by the
time
you know she gets 20 15 seconds for her
critical position
this is the problem you know like as
soon as she gets under half a minute she
this is where she starts to make
blunders historically so she's going to
have to play so well
here i mean i like this move she's got
pressure she's doing okay but
it's the 30-second mark where you your
thinking becomes
so quick he wants a nice move
and using up that back rank if a lesser
takes that queen is going to leap into
e1
the knight on d7 may be trapped but it
could be an asset in an attack
and look at that 20 seconds left oh
you can't take the knight because it'll
be checkmate as well roberto has played
so well in this game he really has 94 is
another very nice move
oh there's a nice tactic there isn't if
you take the knight there's nine
ninety-six maybe your night of six
yeah some ten seconds there we go okay
now
this i mean you have to try i mean look
at the time have to try this move
hoping for queen queen somewhere queen c
yeah queen c 3 when she won
i would take this and then i would go
bishop you maybe
four seconds though h5 knights
bishop f2 bishop h4 look at this
maneuver get that rook
but not here okay ah one second
dang not enough time
g6 may be a bishop before roberto is
going to get that night out he's going
to
medevac that night somehow beautiful
move by herbert
[Music]
wow and let's just show that that what
i'm telling that knight c4
that would have put the game away that
is just pain and let me just rewind back
to that moment knight c2 who
who can blame her for making such a
tempting move but always
you see a good move look for a better
one knight c4 taking away
these squares queen has to take the
punter now the cleanest boom goes the
dynamite back to ca
queen has no squares white can't even
give the queen up for more than a piece
that would have ended it
a heartbreaker absolute heartbreak uber
all credit to roberto
insane resilience such a nice way to win
the queen there daniel as well that that
bishop coming back but
anyway it's not over yet but there's
been some chances
that alicia has missed unfortunately
there's still still some chance daniel
right
oh absolutely there's still a chance
there's the bullet segment
and uh historically we know that
anything can happen in the bullet but
after such a scintillating
three-minute portion players need to
catch their breaths we need to refill
our coffee
seat belts fastened and mandatory don't
go anywhere when we come back
we have the final bullet segment of this
i am not a gm
championship match-up between alessia
santoramo and
robert roberto molina
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
i
am not a gm speed chess championship
brought to you by chess.com
we have the final bullet segments of
this amazing match coming up but before
we jump into that
we wanted to remind everybody if that
arena king's season six
long awaited is already underway there's
a 20 000 prize
uh dollar prize fund everybody's playing
we have picaro alireza
all playing a couple of them there's
tons of prizes tons of hype you
certainly don't want to miss it and the
next
arena kings is tomorrow friday at 5 p.m
pacific
8 p.m in the evening eastern time
but we'll get to that tomorrow but right
now we have the bullet segment
the final 25 minute portion of this
match between alessia santoramo
and roberto molina match that has been
really really fun to watch it's featured
some very high level chess
and simon roberto molina has succeeded
in bringing alessia's
initial 15 point lead down to three
that's
i think as much as he could possibly
hope for before the bullet
yeah definitely i mean it's still a
chance for alicia we're going into the
bullet stage
very shortly but uh roberto's play so
far has been
incredibly impressive he's he's he's
been like houdini when the pressure's
bad he's survived he's finding practical
chances
and he's just playing good chess alicia
has also had
had had her opportunities but her time
handling
is meaning that she's sometimes not
being able to grasp those tactical
moments
it's going to be tough in the bullet but
it's still possible for this year to
keep
the lead definitely i'm not too familiar
with i mean i know alessia plays
a lot of blitz on on her stream
uh i'm not sure how much bullet she
plays it's going to be very important as
we discuss to adjust
immediately no more long things it's all
about intuition it's all about snap
reactions
alessia has shown herself more than
capable of
playing that kind of chess but she's
going to have to embrace that completely
and here we see another
e6 v6 that's where roberto has chosen
basically all matched long a very
interesting position but alessia doing
very well she's about to push d5 here
and this is looking very dubious simon
for for roberto in the early going look
at this
this is losing for black a really
promising start this is what she needs
to do
i mean she's got a major center pawns in
the middle i love the idea of pushing
harry as i always do throw the h pawn
down
though castling is okay this is the kind
of position she needs to convert she's
got a three-point lead
you know if she makes it four points
this she's still in it she's still in
with a shell
she's gotta win i mean i keep saying
she's gotta win this one but with a
position like this
you have to win one positions yeah
anyway no but this move d6 i also
thought about the problem with that move
and unless you're taking too much time
here the problem of that move is that it
gives black's knight the c6 where so it
might have been a little bit hasty
but still i mean this is a huge
initiative for wayne very very hard to
play in a bullet game for black
roberto might just castle here he might
scramble to try to complete his
development i would still consider
pushing harry
at some point here or maybe pushing
frank
oh good old frank the porn this is also
very intense one night just dive in go
for mate
go for late don't look at the queen oh
yeah okay
here's frank oh
get between the knight f7 queen h5 and
knight f7 is a crusher
come on she's done it okay
it's crushing she just got to play this
one
don't ever go back knight f7
just really quickly taking the legs off
of the knight and then the battery is
just checked made in a couple moves
it's still still good for white but one
gets the sense that you just missed a
huge opportunity
that was a major chance to me she's
still got this lovely pawn structure but
now roberto
and that is just an unbelievable
turnaround simon yeah
it's that was that was rather tragic
actually if i mean
okay there's some chance here but if you
look at the position
when she had all her pieces around her
opponent's king
you just look at ways to blast your
opponent's king opening even if it's a
sacrifice
just go for the attack and i think you
know
it's when you've lost a couple of games
maybe you're mentally thinking a bit
more negative
and and that's why um that's why she
didn't go forward so it's that negative
thinking i mean
this line you're demonstrating daniel
completely winning for white there
yeah it was a is a big opportunity huge
and that would have pushed the lead up
to up to four points and
most importantly there's only 25 minutes
of bullet
and that is a heart heartbreaker for
alicia
i can see some people in the twitch chat
mention this as well
and it is really how
cool is roberto he has proven i think as
well it's not
not just that he's been playing great
chess but he's been very calm even there
he must have realized he's completely
lost
but he moves instantaneous and soon as a
position changes and he takes his
opportunities you've got to take your
opportunities
the score now only two points in it 21
minutes to go
well i you know i don't like it
something's gotta something's gotta
change right
right something i mean the thing is uh
my coach would often tell me this one of
the keys to defending
narrow the path narrow the path to your
opponents
uh to your opponent's victory force your
opponent to find an
only move and if they don't find it
then if they find it you tip your head
if they don't find it you get a chance
that's what he did with knight takes
step seven as soon as alessia missed
that
roberto pounds immediately and he has
been doing this
all match well yeah he has he's been
taking his opportunities when they're
not grasped and that's all you can do
when you're in a bad position uh it
seems like he has a slight advantage
here but
nothing too bad at the moment um
and again with 20 minutes left that's a
fair few games
of bullet so alicia has to win if she's
got any chance at some point
she has to win a game or two to keep
this match alive at the moment
she's playing well though i mean she is
she's holding it together
i mean the thing is in a lot of these
games daniel she seems to be even out
playing
roberto and she's getting good positions
but it's just then just letting it slip
through her fingers not finding the
killer blow and that's
an important skill to have you've got to
find the knockout blow
there's not much time in your clock i
don't like the way this is going
white dominating the open fire seven
yeah
it doesn't look good this the black king
slightly weak
and yeah as you predicted that is going
to win at least a pawn
in the position queen e7 would one would
lose a queen to rook d7 i mean
black is a cool trick there queen e7 or
d7 king fb
but um it's just that shouldn't be good
enough and
now the clock ticking down rookie seven
and now
um queen takes e7 is just crushing
because
these rooks are just rook d7 is
unstoppable and if king f6
rook d7 is going to win the queen wow
that's a cool idea here by roberto and
now
alessio forced to give up her queen and
it's off yeah
and you can see from her body language
as well
you know it's getting to her a little
bit i mean it would be
and it's very easy to get demoralized at
this stage i mean
obviously now roberto massive massive
massive favorite
yes but you know i don't see her coming
back from this but you know you've got
to keep trying
she's got another white just do the same
opening you did before
carragher understand and one of the most
solid
solid car cons available in the knight
f6 faragon
yeah so night's coming out
and now okay
one point in the in the match now 18
minutes to go
more pieces get exchanged i expect more
comfortable black gets in these kind of
positions
yep it's a slight edge for a way but but
roberto's very experienced clearly in
these structures they've had these
structures arise
frequently almost every game through the
french and through the b6
lines that roberto has played super
solid position but the battle revolves
around
who is going to be better prepared when
c5 comes
that's the question the position kind of
explodes it sharpens up
uh and and what black is relying on here
are these these
sniper bishops on c5 and v7 yeah i'm not
sure i like that f4 move because it
it actually gives those bishops more
power i mean it's an aggressive move
but it's quite hard to make use of the
pawn on f4 here and now
black again creating threats
okay well this is this is i mean okay
black's gonna win the exchange but at
least the white queen has sneaked into
black's position
so any chance to use that queen because
you see the problem is
these two pieces would have combined by
that queen on c7
yeah it's guarding the g7 square and
it's very very hard and the pawn on f5
is putting the bishop out of commission
oh bishop g2 is going to be a crusher
here or even knight takes you to
those bishops you did call them sniper
bishops and they're they're looking
pretty deadly there
aren't they look how strong they are i
mean you're even threatening
to nearly move that knight and give
check mate because of the bishops it's a
crazy position but
the best chance here is probably queen
takes night i mean yeah
you know just just get the two pieces
and pray um
but i think this is going to level level
the score now
17 minutes to go so bishop i mean
roberto is very impressive
he's looking more and more impressive as
the time goes
yeah i am really going to be a contender
for the whole competition
he is without a doubt i mean he's so
versatile we've seen versatility has
been a winner
across the board bishop before his check
made in a couple years
brilliant look at that wow oh this is a
nice finish
look at that finish i'll show that again
oh look at those
sniper bishops you talked about them
unbelievable
bishops there um score is level
yep and it's a tie game time match 16
minutes to go
hey it ain't over till it's over but
it's just one gets the sense of
robertson so confidently
yeah he is uh his confidence is growing
he knows it's a tied match now
he can kind of relax as well can't you
because it's like you're always behind
now he's tied it's like right okay i'm
now i'm
it's the first time in a match he's been
tied he could go ahead if he wins this
one then
it's just gonna get worse and worse for
this year unfortunately
yeah and playing prophylactically his
positional understanding too has been
pretty impressive he stopped
some of these ideas alessia trying to
get this f5 idea and this knight h5927
is a very good maneuver by the way
to prepare f5 uh now the ball in
roberto's court
uh because this king's indian these
kings indian types of positions
because blind you mentioned this earlier
simon these positions where you have a
set
kind of series of moves a simple plan
like that f6 though but they can be a
lot easier to play even if
uh your crowns i think unless he's
trying to go knight g8 at some point but
that's to a little bit too much
preparation because
now robert is going to go knight b5 and
he's going to start
operations on the queen side yeah i
agreed i mean
you want simple plans and uh i think
that f-borne
should have been shoved down the board
and every kind of tempo
makes a difference here but okay what is
knight d3
okay okay all now that is the exchange
it is the exchange and f5 has come okay
you can see this is the first time i've
seen some emotion from roberto as well
i haven't seen him crack like that but
can she win one positions
that's the point she's got to win she's
already made a mistake though because
that knight on e4 is now a huge blockade
rookie on but
look at the time situation roberto also
one of the first times he is down
seriously on the clock in the bullet
game can alessia hold it together maybe
look half seven
get that rook in there defend the
seventh rank
don't take too much time easy to say
hard to do night a seven now an idea
i i don't mind there's so much like
because at least it's a proactive move
get the rook
into c2 i think this is good
you know it's still she's still in there
with a shout here um
she's got the time advantage but roberto
again this is what roberto's doing he
makes a blunder okay he shook
his head next move he's back on the game
bang bang
and uh this is where he's been so
impressive he's just such a he's a
strong character you can tell that
immediately yeah experience experience
strong knows how to bounce back this
last move don't necessarily like
with the i mean okay it's still unclear
14 seconds yeah between f7 is a good
move doubling up 94
come on get in look at that knight on e4
it's defending f2 rook 62 is a big
threat though
and roberto calm as a cucumber
yeah i've never understood that phrase i
suppose it's because cucumbers are
pretty bad
right yeah they're cool they're cool
they stay cool they're cool
i don't like it but oh dear oh look
after
you rook f2 oh come on just punch it
queen comes in the ending i thought okay
not over yet not over yet four seconds
too slow
that pawn's unstoppable or is it rook d3
knight d6
oh bishop f6 it's actually still a game
black is winning bro
look at this b5 now the other pawn is
going to start rolling
no roberto gets his king into e2 alessia
trying to use her rook strikes e1 who
takes the two
and that pawn is going to evaporate and
so do black strong chances
oh man bishop is so tragic right i mean
just by the
narrow it's not that even she's making
any big letters it's just he's
he's keeping that pressure going all
right i mean for the
you have to remember that the gap in
their elo's is quite
large yeah it's like is you're looking
at four or five hundred points i think
but
the way that alicia is playing is very
small on the board she's getting chances
she's fighting back
but just not quite you know roberto has
that extra
little gear at the end and this is the
first time he's been in the lead
in the match so really alyssia
needs a bit of a miracle now with 12
minutes to go
it's going to be very tough now can we
see that smile
on her face and for those interested in
the ratings roberto
in terms of p day ratings he is 24 34
alessia 2160
um of course absolutely nothing to
sneeze at but
uh that you know he's been in i am for
many years he's so experienced
and uh and that just tells you know that
you can see the consistency
that's perhaps the word that comes to
mind maybe no brilliancies but
uh but he's played tons of good moves
very very consistently
very few blonders that's important
yeah i mean he seems he seems to know
certain structures
and you sort of see this and when he's
playing black as in these kind of
positions
he's going for this pawn structure we're
seeing here this is an important tool to
use
once you get used to playing the same
pawn structure time and time again
you know where the pieces should go you
know what exchanges to make
you even know what endings you want when
you play the the first couple of moves
and
this shows his experience and this is
something we all should aim to do get
experience in positions
know what you're aiming for and that is
also a factor
that that's uh helped him a lot in his
score here
indeed and here again
a very nice end game for leslie
aggressive play i've liked the way that
she's handled her she's
doing really well she's playing really
well absolutely is and
white is better here but and white can
still attack black team
a move that could be quite crafty here
is something like knight g4
and then that but there we go and then i
could sack himself on f5
she's playing brilliantly in this game
brilliant yeah i mean
when you've got more space when you're
attacking generally keep the pieces on
the board and she's using
harry come on harry get some squares
she's playing really well
i don't know about age six though simon
that left that knight on that fade back
okay so this is this is often what she's
doing she's playing this great chess in
the early middle game but
around this point her clocks getting a
bit low and she's
not getting that final kind of attacking
maybe here there's just
nothing with black defending very well
he's a very good defender as well
you got great better every type of
position and
you have you don't see a single game
where he just kind of
throws his hands up and says ah you know
i'll give her this game you know
this game is not my game every game is
his game every game he tries to find
objectively the best chances that's a
quality of a of a winner yeah i mean
he's making it hard in every position
definitely never giving up and
that time is still ticking down
there's no attack here the night the
knight on the side of the board is just
just a bad piece here uh and black
more centralized this is often this is
another theme i've noticed that
roberto is often just centralizing his
pieces a lot better
it's okay putting your pieces on the
side of the board on occasions
if they got a real aim or they're doing
something concrete
but in this situation that knight is not
doing anything
on the side of the board so it's looking
bad five seconds left as well oh but
look at that
this is actually one situation where she
probably wants to get on to the next
game
right i mean her only chance okay it's
unlikely now of course but
i think in nearly every game daniel in
the bullet section she's been winning
at one stage every single game she's
been winning
it's the converting which is the hard
part and i think this is what a lot of
people say it's actually
it is the converting of advantages which
is one of the biggest skills to learn
it really is really hard and i can't
criticize because it's been one of my
biggest weaknesses throughout my chest
career you just your hands start to
shake
you know you start to feel that
nervousness you know why am i not
finding the fastest win
and nothing is more frustrating than
knowing
because you know when you're winning you
almost always can just know it
but uh you know you're winning and you
can't find it and that frustration is
unimaginable
yeah i totally agree and and it's it's
it's also like
when when you're winning your opponent
often if they're a real fighter like
obviously roberto
is in this game in this match they
they're sort of like an animal backed up
in a corner they get their teeth out and
they fight they've got nothing to lose
they become more dangerous
and you've got to remember that rather
than relaxing which most people do when
they gain an advantage
you should actually be more on guard
because your opponent has less to lose
you can take more chances so converting
advantages
never relax until the game is over such
a big thing in chess
absolutely and you know people ask well
how has just chess
changed as a you know a result of 50
years as a result of the advent of
computers and
i think one of the most noticeable
things is just the the
overall tremendous exponential increase
in the
uh ability of people to defend bad
positions across the board
not just uh in terms of a select few
players
but you see players like roberto iam's
gm's fm's
almost everybody has acquired this this
renewed fighting spirit whereas
sometimes if you looked at games of
the past you know not to suggest that
there weren't amazing defenders
you know like the trojan but uh at you
know some of the lower levels
i think the players were faster to admit
defeat they were faster to
congratulate their opponent game role
play now
you compare these players to tigers
that's just
that's the norm rather than the
exception and that's great
yeah i agree i mean it's quite funny
because if you look back at the games of
paul morphy who is the the legend from
new orleans and
he was his fantastic attacking genius
but
i don't want to be rude but if you look
at the quality of the way his opponents
defended
if it was a game nowadays you'd say his
opponents were just weak they defended
terribly
they defended they didn't even put they
didn't even
at today's level you they would never be
up there and in the top hundred players
they've defended meekly and that skill
of defending has just increased and
increased
over the years if morphe played the way
he did nowadays
he may struggle if he played the same
stuff i mean of course
he'd adapt to the time but defensive
play has just become like
as you say daniel much more appreciated
because computers have shown
how to defend certain positions i feel
yeah and we see some
i mean i don't think either of us is
suggesting that morphe was anything sort
of brilliant
nor diminishing his tremendous
contribution to the development of the
game the guy was
an absolute legend the genius but uh
still it makes sense in terms of
uh kind of narrating understanding the
transformation of chess we can
uh you know admit the you know the
improvements that have made and at the
same time recognize
the achievements so this is not to
diminish anything that he or
his opponent said but the fact remains
the
attitude really has changed and it also
is reflected in the fact that
there's just more chess professionals
now and there's more people who who take
the game
you know scientifically for whom it
really is the livelihood whether they
win or lose back then
you know some players were even at the
high levels were you know sort of had a
cigar dangling from their
from their mouths and you know they were
munching on a baguette
yeah you know very good paul murphy is
this is
a genius play yes i will let you
sacrifice
and lose okay i don't know why well that
came but
you know what i mean i want to hear more
of your uh you know your
you know your representation so far
that's good with morphe i like that that
was a good one
yeah i haven't done any accents today i
haven't had the occasion to but perhaps
the chance will arise
yeah it's quite funny though because if
you go back to the days of paul mcmurphy
it was actually considered okay your
opponent sacrifices a piece against you
it was considered un-gentleman-like if
you did not accept the sacrifice
so you know your person offers your rook
and you're supposed to take that rook
otherwise
you lose a bit of your people be like oh
i look at him such and
so he's not a gentleman he didn't accept
the sound right exactly
and you know like coffee house chess
they call it and
you have the crowd there they want to
see glory on the board
nowadays obviously if your opponent
offers you a sacrifice
and by taking it you get a bad position
you'd be crazy to take it
a draw there okay that's a good draw
that's stopping the rock a little bit
um i kind of like the coffee house chest
bring back the coffee houses
you know absolutely yeah we need more
coffee house crates we need a little bit
more of that i completely agree some
more speculative sacrifices
definitely well we do we do have duboff
don't we and
people like that so people are still
playing in that way at the moment just a
little bit more
um you know refined i guess
anyway good that alicia stopped the rot
there and again she's got a good
position here i mean this this looks to
me like black's king
is weaker than white's king the white's
king is safer so
it must be a bit better for her maybe g4
just go there is
time for two more games okay so if she
wins this one
okay it's a two-point game as far as
last time i checked okay this and she's
getting she's getting ready for g4 here
yeah she's gone g4 traps the bishop
that bishop he's trapped but bishop five
actually bishop f5 is still a chance
because that opens up the g
file speaking of copy house chess by the
way gotta embrace
[Music]
unfortunately pawn takes queen as check
which is annoying
checks and uh yeah that's the match that
could be
well the ee was even faster but this
works rookie two oh
that's a nasty little move yeah
yeah you know the end of the day
roberto's consistency prevails but
alessia can
hold her head up high she she played
very high quality chest throughout the
match and
you know i'm not just saying that's uh
you know attempt to make her feel better
she really did
and by the way we are i i think going to
have interviews with the players so
do do hang around for that at the end
just be nice nice to hear their opinions
and
if you've got any questions in the chat
then that you'd like to ask them
it's probably i'll keep an eye on the
chat probably a good time to throw
those questions in now
and so and i just wanted to read off
um robert of course we missed you
but gm has robert making a very astute
comment i i wanted to read that off
hey everyone here's my take if someone
has covered every chest of impossible
playing chess is hard
alessia has done tremendous fight and
even as outplayed roberto in certain
stretches
completely second that of course roberto
the higher rated and stronger player
most people would not even be willing to
play a match like this given that you're
about to suffer many losses
but it's a great opportunity to face
often as a strong player and learn from
the experience i think that's a very
very good take and that cannot be
underestimated you know you know
unless you knows coming to this match
you know that even if she
would have won i mean you you're gonna
take a pummeling
and um you know she deserves tremendous
credit for
holding her head up high and keeping
you know continuing to put an effort
every single game with that being said
roberto deserves equal credit for for a
tremendously played match that's what
makes chess great
both players can take away very positive
experiences from a match like this
i think so yeah i totally agree and um
alicia
she's played well i mean you know she
has outplayed
a much higher rated and more experienced
and stronger opponent on numerous
occasions she's got
winning positions she's put him under
pressure and she's
proven that she's got a lot of talent
and has a lot you know she could improve
massively from her rating at the moment
so
you've got to take away the positives
from something like this obviously it's
depressing to lose
anything really chess related but she
has
proven herself as a very dangerous and
good
opponent here for for roberto absolutely
in some ways i think there's the score
line doesn't really reflect reflect how
how close the match has been it should
have taken just a
little percentage of those opportunities
she had she would have won this match
and uh you know that's a big thing do
check out their stream channels as well
both these two
people stream alicia streams quite early
in the morning if you're in europe
i would say maybe late at night in
america but go and follow her twitch
channel
and i'm i haven't actually seen roberto
stream ever i'm sorry about that roberto
it might be a different time to me but i
know he has his own youtube channel
and twitch channel so obviously worth
following them
and um also checking out what they're
looking at live streams
a lot of fun particularly here speak
portuguese
uh he's very well-rounded player i'm
sure he puts out
uh tremendously instructive content on
on his youtube channel
alessia um i've definitely popped into
her stream quite a few times and
you know she's so high energy she puts
her effort into it and definitely
definitely worth the follow
uh and that with this checkmate on t6
concludes and they will abort this game
that concludes the match final scores
21-17
as international master roberto molina
plays tremendously to win the match
and alessia an amazing fight all
throughout
we will definitely delve into this match
as we will interview the players
so do not go anywhere we will take a
quick break when we return
interviews with these two gladiators um
upon the conclusion of this match
so
and welcome back ladies and gentlemen to
the i am not a gm speed
chess championship brought to you by
chess.com the match
between women's fplacia sanoramo and
international master roberto molina has
just concluded
uh roberto and we have the players here
for a
quick post game interview we're very
excited to hear their thoughts
uh first of all uh roberto
congratulations on an
excellently played match what would you
say were some of the keys to your
victory what do you think that you did
particularly well to guide yourself to
that victory um
i prepared some lines
[Laughter]
tricky blitz lines and
she enters in in two of dance
uh for example the false french the
fake french with b6
and uh i i saw some
nakamura games in this type of position
and i think i learned something
and the other position in the english
opening
i prepared that little bit
but in one game it was a total disaster
with knight f5 but
i think that the opening preparation to
blitz match help is something
i don't know it seems like you you kept
your call
very well um when when the position was
maybe getting very tricky
you you were calculated very quickly and
uh
you kept defending incredibly incredibly
accurately
i think so well done yes yeah good match
i think we're all curious alessia when
you put that helmet on
you won a brilliant game tell us more
about that helmets because
we were all taken by that well actually
it was
pretty random yesterday um i went to it
at
home of the father of my boyfriend and
we went just shortly downstairs to see
all the old stuff and i found this
actually there is a complete set that i
was too shy to
to wear and there is even a sword
i wanted really to fight and so but at
least i was brave enough to
wear this and it brought log it worked
you won a very nice game when you
brought a hotel yeah it was great
wins that that game when your boot is
masked yeah you know so yeah sadly that
i don't know why i removed it i was just
so stupid
i should have kept it on that was the
major problem yeah
yeah we diagnosed the reason yeah i mean
you played
yeah go ahead i was just going to say
yeah you
you played really good chess it seemed i
mean you you got some great positions
you kept the pressure on
obviously much lower rated than roberto
but
you you played well and uh i don't think
the result always reflected that but
some positives to take away right yeah
for sure for sure now i'm actually proud
to that i played good chess and i got
some chances
sometimes i didn't use them sometimes
few times i use them
and so at the end i mean international
master modlina
i heard that is soon a gm something like
this
so it's very strong and i'm happy about
um at least the good chess more or less
uh i saw some games of alessia he's a
very very good attack player
[Music]
yeah i wanted to attack but it was hard
that makes perfect sense well fine we
know
both of you are very tired final
question for you uh roberto going into
the next
uh matches that you're going to play
anything that you might want to change
any particular ways that you think
you're going to prepare
or are you just going to take it one
match at a time
i don't have any idea what's going what
will happen but i think i will
saw some openings trick another
against larry strange but i'm interested
you're playing lawrence who's who's very
tricky guy right
okay okay but you
played very strong it's going to be a
great great match to watch let's see the
trick match it's going to be exciting
definitely
absolutely well uh we won't keep either
of you any longer alessia roberto thank
you so much
for an amazing match we were all
thoroughly entertained congratulations
to robertson
very well played alessia we will let you
take your well-deserved break
thank you thanks
thanks wow simon
we got everything we could have asked
for roberto emerges victorious in the
end but
as we discussed amazingly well played by
alessia and uh
you know these matches are so
interesting and as we look at the
bracket we've got so many more of them
to come
yeah i mean it's it's it's i'm really
looking forward to seeing that you know
how roberto gets on against lawrence
because they they both played
i saw both of the first round matches
and they both played
really well uh i mean they're both
contenders
i think to win the whole thing uh other
matches that we've got to look forward
to well
it's just so many you've got yeah made
major streamers in there you've got
major chess
personalities you've got young talent
what what uh what a great event this is
absolutely and i know a lot of people
looking forward to levy's progress he's
going to play the winner of costa
kabootsky against tanya sasha we could
see sagar shah
i'm really excited to see him to see him
playing him a big eric rosen fan
and uh greg shahadi not to be
underestimated as well
uh he's part of the old guard but greg's
a beast so this is
again an amazing field put forward by
chess.com and uh
it just shows that super tournaments are
great you know tata steel's gonna be
great but
uh this is not to be underestimated
every single one of these players is
putting themselves on the line putting
their blood sweat and tears into each
match
and that's really what brings us to to
the next level son
yeah certainly it's great seeing that
you know made the internet chess live on
for
many years so perfect and uh
as always you know i'd just like to say
it's been a pleasure uh
commentating with you daniel and thank
you everyone who's tuned in
it's been a lot of fun likewise simon
it's uh
always an honor uh yeah i'm a big fan
and uh this has been just amazing and
i think we want to thank thousands over
ten thousand over twenty thousand
of you who were taking time uh out of
your
busy thursdays watching this match and
contributing to the chat
uh this is really brought to the next
level because of you
and um on behalf of us
gm daniel meredith the one and only
ginger gm grandmaster simon williams
covering the i am not a gm speech
championship
there's a lot of action yet to come we
will see you in the next match
but for now stay safe everybody have a
great rest of your thursday and a great
weekend
and so on
you